général comme on dit en commission sur
le même modèle que les discussions
générales telles qu'elles se déroulent
en séance plénière de l'assemblée
nationale dans notre hémicycle selon les
règles adoptées lors de la dernière
réforme du règlement et nous aurons donc
un temps de parole d'abord des ministres
puis des rapporteurs du rapporteur
général bien sûr il des rapporteurs
thématiques qui ont accepté de limiter
leur temps de parole à trois minutes et
je les en remercie de façon ensuite
avoir les orateurs de groupes qui auront
chacune et chacun cinq minutes chaque
groupe quelle que soit sa taille a le
même temps de parole et je vous propose
que s'il nous reste du temps ensuite
nous ayons dans la mesure du possible la
possibilité pour quelques collègues
supplémentaires d'intervenir mais pour
une durée d'une minute et ensuite nous
terminerons exceptionnellement à 20
heures puisque nous avons commencé un
peu plus tard que ce qui était prévu
pour reprendre à 21h30 et commencer à
21h30 les examens l'examen pardon des
articles et des amendements à ce sujet
je veux donner quelques informations et
pour ma part j'assume totalement
car j'ai lu ici ou là quelques
journalistes m'ont interrogé en
demandant si on pouvait pour un sujet
aussi important
s'en remettre aux fonctionnaires de
l'assemblée nationale alors je dois tout
de suite dire d'abord que je remercie
les fonctionnaires de l'assemblée
nationale pour leur travail de très
grande qualité pour nous permettre de
juger de ce qui est recevable ou pas
mais que c'est bel et bien moi en tant
que président de la commission cela m'a
pris un certain temps d'ailleurs ce
week-end qui est décidé et j'assume
totalement ce qui est du ressort des
présidents de commission et je rappelle
que cet article 45
il a été fait tout simplement pour que
sur chaque projet de loi on ne refasse
pas tout la loi dans tous les domaines
et que on amendes sur les sujets qui
sont traités dans le projet de loi c'est
le lien direct ou indirect avec le
projet de loi et c'est ce que ne manque
pas de nous rappeler régulièrement
le conseil constitutionnel chargé
d'appliquer notre constitution
et bien sûr je le dis aussi si jamais
tel ou tel avait des doutes je sais que
les procès d'intention ne sont jamais
loin mais ils sont toujours loin de la
réalité est bien en l'occurrence les
recevabilité a été déclarée sur les
amendements venant de tous les groupes
donc alors je dois dire s'il pas
l'honnêteté que le groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine n'avait déposé
aucun amendement il recevable
quand même le dire mais tous les autres
groupes et les députés non-inscrits
également avait pu et ça arrive à tout
le monde
je suis député depuis fort longtemps
cela m'est arrivé très souvent
alors je vais tout de suite de passer
la parole tout d'abord à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
merci monsieur le président monsieur
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les députés ça dure mais mes collègues
de ministre je vous remercie évidemment
du temps long que votre assemblée a déjà
consacré le texte de loi que j'ai
l'honneur de présenter avec mme aïcha
pas et gouvernement au nom du président
ministre bien sûr sur un sujet
extrêmement important dont il ne revient
en quelques mots de faire une
introduction vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président et qui sans doute dans le
débat en séance publique amènera
davantage d'opposition encore politique
politico bon sens du terme parce que la
république est attaquée et c'est normal
qu'elle se défende ses légitimes
qu'elles prennent des mesures pour se
défendre elle est attaquée par le
terrorisme et la découverte sans
précédent
quelle que soit la couleur politique ont
donné des armes à la justice et bien sûr
au ministère de l'intérieur pour
intervenir mais elle est aussi attaquée
par le terreau du terrorisme ce que le
présent en afrique appelé les
séparatismes parmi ces séparatisme le
premier le plus dangereux celui qu'il
nous faut combattre ici maintenant et
celui du séparatisme islamistes mais il
ya aussi d'autres séparatisme on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
et surtout demain ou après demain parce
que nous faisons pas une loi simplement
pour aujourd'hui comme le sans doute
l'avait fait nos nos prédécesseurs il ya
bien longtemps puisque cette loi était
présente et 115 ans jour pour jour après
la loi de séparation des églises et des
tailles et de la fin du concordat a été
fait évidemment pour pour l'avenir
alors ce point évidemment pour d'où il
vient du discours des bureaux du
président de la république après notre
très grand travail de concertation qui
avait été fait avant ce discours je dois
saluer mes prédécesseurs au ministère de
l'intérieur gérard collomb et christophe
castaner et puis bien sûr à partir du
discours des mureaux un grand travail de
conservation que nous avons tous
beaucoup mener et puis vous même
monsieur le président monsieur
rapporteur général dames et messieurs
les députés dans les auditions longue
passionnante intéressante et gageons que
devant de telles
assertion il nous devons continuer ce
travail de concertation
c'est un texte qui est là pour conforter
les principes de la république
il n'est pas là pour l'échangé il n'est
pas bien pour les modifier
il est là pour les conforter car nous
sommes persuadés que les principes de la
république et singulièrement le principe
de laïcité est le meilleur remède à
cette attaque contre la république
renforcer le principe de neutralité de
le verrons qui est évidemment un
principe une composante comme le répète
sans cesse à la fois la jurisprudence
le conseil d'état la cour
constitutionnelle mais aussi ce
parlement pour le service public et pour
ceux qui concourent
mais il n'est pas là pour changer le
principe de neutralité et d'appliquer
aux usagers du service public ce
principe de neutralité
il est là pour renforcer le principe
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
madame la ministre déléguée reviendra
très certainement il a pour renforcer le
principe de liberté parce que la liberté
de conscience la liberté de culte
évidemment est une composante également
de la laïcité et nous savons que les
cultes les croyants les religions
concours évidemment à faire de notre
république une république apaisée et
qu'elle n'est pas une loi contre elle et
noah pour la république et nous allons
donc voir des renforcement sans
précédent également de la police des
cultes et de la gestion de ces cultes le
gestion évidemment qui va sans doute
passionné les débats et puis en
forcément de l'ordre public sans qui la
liberté ne serait qu'un vain mot prévu
dès la déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir
alors ce texte il est fait bien sûr pour
lutter contre les séparatismes
j'évoquais de séparatisme vista liste il
n'est pas là pour régler telle ou telle
question qui relève du dogme ou qui
relève de l'action de telle ou telle
église
l'état doit bien d'une main tremblante
regarder les choses
certes la république ne reconnaît aucun
culte elle peut les discuter avec eux
même si personne évidemment n'est
principalement traité par la république
depuis 1905 mais nous sommes surtout là
aussi pour nous défendre de l'islamisme
politique
il s'amuse le politique qui a fait une
opa sur l'islam et singulièrement son
système de france et nous n'oublions pas
que les premiers veille première victime
de l'islamisme sont les musulmans
à travers le monde et je voudrais
d'ailleurs saluée même si un texte de
loi ne fait pas référence en vertu
notamment articles 1er et 2e de la 2d
pardon de la loi 1905 de l'accord de la
charte qui a été trouvé entre les
représentants de l'islam de france ce
matin devant le la présence du président
de la république documents que je vous
ai fait parvenir dès sa signature
alors voilà monsieur le président c'est
un texte de liberté avec des grandes
libertés qui sont évoqués liberté
d'association liberté de culte liberté
de conscience
mais c'est aussi un texte d'autorité que
le gouvernement assume afin de faire
respecter les principes de la république
ceux qui fondent la nation française et
qui espérons encore pendant des siècles
la fonderie je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre je passe
maintenant la parole à madame marlène
schiappa ministre délégué auprès de vous
messieurs mise de l'intérieur ministre
chargé de la citoyenneté
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres monsieur le président de
commission de ce rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs et
mesdames et messieurs les députés
d'abord je suis ravi d'être avec vous
aujourd'hui pour le début de l'examen en
commission spéciale de ce projet lois
confortant le respect des principes de
la république
ce texte vous savez le ministre de
l'intérieur jawad al manar l'a rappelé
nous l'avons présenté en conseil des
ministres le 9 décembre à l'occasion des
cent quinze ans de la loi de 1905 élit
le fruit de larges consultations qui ont
été conduites par le ministère de
l'intérieur et par d'autres ministères
avec la société civile avec les partis
politiques avec les représentants des
cultes les intellectuels les
associations philosophique et vous avez
d'ailleurs vous même mené de nombreuses
et fructueuses audition nous aurons le
plaisir d'échanger traite à l'heure
l'objectif de ce texte il est clair
c'est de défendre nos valeurs et la
promesse républicaine la promesse de
liberté est la promesse d'émancipation
alors je ne reviendrai pas sur les
articles mentionnés par le miz
l'intérieur gérald darmanin mais je
voudrais plus particulièrement avec vous
évoquez les mesures relatives au droit
des associations et à la dignité humaine
je voudrais d'abord rendre un hommage à
toutes celles et ceux qui sont engagés
dans la vie
associative et qu'ils font au quotidien
vivre nos territoires et nos communes ce
dynamisme et ses richesses qui sont
offertes dans des domaines aussi variés
que le sport les loisirs la culture les
arts etc
son teint singularisme dont nous pouvons
être fiers
en france et cet engagement je crois
qu'il fait sens parce qu'il s'inscrit
dans le ciment républicain et c'est
pourquoi au travers de ce projet de loi
nous avons voulu rappeler la
souveraineté absolue des principes de la
république sous tout autre système
normatif y compris dans ce monde et cela
passe par la neutralité des services
publics mais aussi par un meilleur
encadrement des activités associatives
afin d'empêcher qu'ils prospèrent les
discours et les pratiques contraires aux
valeurs de la république ce sont les
articles 6 et 7
je les dis nous l'avons dit je le répète
ici notre volonté c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas un euro d'argent public pour les
ennemis de la république et donc toute
association sollicitant une subvention
publique sous quelque forme que ce soit
devra désormais signé un contrat
d'engagement républicain par lequel elle
s'engage à respecter les valeurs de la
république
comme je l'avais mise en place
d'ailleurs sous mes précédentes
fonctions mais cette fois en le faisant
entrer dans la loi et nous souhaitons
véritablement poursuivre conjointement
ce travail avec le ministre de
l'intérieur nous avons décidé qu'il
ferait l'objet d'un décret d'application
en conseil d'état et nous l'écrivons les
consultations se poursuivent avec les
associations avec notre collègue
s'arrête à erie et avec les
organisations qui représentent les élus
avec notre collègue jacqueline nouveau
nous avons initié ces deux processus de
consultation ils se poursuivent et je
voudrais d'ores et déjà remercier toutes
celles et tous ceux qui se sont engagés
dans cette démarche nous introduisons un
mécanisme de suspension ou de
rétrocession de la subvention versée
dans ce contrat d'engagement républicain
qui peut je le sais suscité quelques
questions parfois quelques inquiétudes
mais je voudrais ici rassurer notre
objectif c'est d'éviter tout amalgame
entre les associations qui participent
de l'offre républicaine et celle
minoritaires qui véhiculent
insidieusement des valeurs contraires
aux principes républicains et donc nous
avons pu le mesurer concrètement nos
travaux notamment pardon autres au
travers des travaux menés par les cuire
les cellules de lutte contre l'islamisme
et le repli communautaire
le respect des principes de la
république c'est aussi celui de la
dignité humaine de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes
les idéologies séparatistes l attaque en
premier lieu les femmes en voulant
décidé à la à leur place ce qu'elles ont
le droit de faire ou de ne pas faire
c'est pourquoi l'article 13 bis à
veiller à l'égalité de traitement entre
les héritiers les articles 14 et 15
pause une réserve générale de polygamie
pour la délivrance de séjour l'article
16 prévoit l'interdiction aux
professionnels de santé d'établir des
certificats de virginité l'article 17
renforce la lutte contre les mariages
forcés
enfin je voudrais dire un mot pour
conclure sur la question de la laïcité
soutenir la promotion et la défense de
la laïcité c'est aussi pour le
gouvernement déposé des amendements que
nous pourrons discuter pour renforcer le
portage et le pilotage et la défense de
la laïcité y compris au sein de
l'appareil d'état
nous auront par ailleurs l'occasion
d'aborder de nouveaux autres sujets qui
ont été proposées via vos amendements
c'est là toute la richesse du travail
parlementaire et je tiens à le rappeler
l'objectif de cette fois pour nous est
clair il est de lutter contre toutes les
formes de séparatisme qui gangrène notre
société et de conforter les principes de
la république
voilà en ce qui concerne le travail que
j'ai eu l'honneur et le plaisir de mener
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur et que
nous allons continuer à mener ensemble
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est
maintenant à monsieur jean michel
blanquer re ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse et des
sports
excusez moi
merci monsieur le président fin mai mais
c'est le rapporteur mais l'ancien député
et mes chers collègues du gouvernement
je suis évidemment très heureux d'être
avec vous dans ce moment important de ce
processus législatif forcément
approfondie sur un sujet aussi important
et vous le savez les volets éducation
association et sport de ce projet de loi
sont évidemment une certaine importance
ils viennent conforter le respect des
principes de la république tel que nous
le voulons ce projet de loi répond à un
enjeu que nous connaissons tous qui est
la lutte contre le séparatisme et
personne ne doute que c'est à l'école
que les choses commencent
de ce point de vue là le les articles
qui concernent l'éducation la jeunesse
et les sports dans ce dans ce projet de
loi sont complémentaires d'un travail
législatif qui a déjà eu lieu et c'est
donc un jalon important dans un
processus qui a commencé depuis
plusieurs années je pense à la loi gatel
qui nous permet désormais de nous
opposer avec efficacité à l'ouverture
d'écoles hors contrat selon des projets
qui ne respecteraient pas des valeurs de
la république
et puis je pense à la voix pour l'école
de la confiance qui a plusieurs
dispositions qui sont utiles aussi dans
ce cadre comme par exemple
l'interdiction du prosélytisme aux
abords des établissements il s'agit
cette fois-ci de en cohérence avec ce
qui vient d'être dit par le ministre de
l'intérieur et par la mini délégué
d'arriver à ce que dans le domaine
scolaire un certain nombre d'angles
morts puisse ne plus exister
il ya une disposition qui a attiré
beaucoup d'attention mais elle n'est pas
la seule c'est la disposition relative à
l'instruction en famille nous y
reviendrons évidemment 7
disposition à mes yeux est une étape
importante dans la définition du cadre
de la liberté d'enseignement la liberté
d'enseigner n'est pas comme n'est pas
quelque chose qui doit rester trop
indéfini toutes les libertés ont besoin
d'être défini et le fait de les définir
mieux contribuer à les renforcer
c'est le cas avec ce projet de loi
s'agissant de l'instruction en famille
qui évidemment a besoin à la fois d'une
définition et de la définition d'un
cadre n'avons pas été sourd à aux
différentes objections qui ont été
formulés je consomme associations de
familles qui défend de l'instruction en
famille et dont on pouvait comprendre
les inquiétudes est en tout cas les
questionnements
c'est pourquoi il ya eu plusieurs phases
de discussion il ya le dialogue avec le
conseil d'état évidemment qui nous a
permis de trouver déjà un premier point
d' équilibre permettant de savoir un
régime d'exception au système déclaratif
et d'autorisation que nous avons mis sur
pied
cela est évidemment n'a pas achevé le
dialogue nous sommes là vont continuer
et donc aujourd'hui nous avons entendu
encore un certain nombre de
préoccupations qu'on va sans doute
entoure entendre maintenant encore
notamment sur la date de mise en oeuvre
de la loi lorsqu'elle serait promulguée
et puis aussi la question de la prise en
compte du projet pédagogique au titre du
quatrième motif d' accès à l'instruction
en famille sur ces deux points on est
encore susceptible de faire faire des
évolutions à ce texte
mais l'objectif est bien de ne pas
perdre l'esprit initial que l'on trouve
dans le discours des mureaux du
président que chacun doit encore avoir
l'esprit puisque là et notre
l'intentionnalité initial et 7
intentionnalité c'est de lutter contre
un phénomène qui a pris beaucoup
d'ampleur
j'ai parfois entendu qu'on le mesure est
mal mais c'est justement l'un des
problèmes il est difficile à mesurer il
ya des angles morts de la république sur
certains territoires
je suis parfois surpris d'entendre
certaines personnes tenir comme acquis
le fait que dans certains endroits il ya
des structures clandestines et qu'on
devrait
ce le tenir comme quelque chose de fatal
ça n'est pas le cas à nos yeux nous
devons nous donner tous les outils et je
rappelle que lorsque nous avons avec le
ministre de l'intérieur démanteler
certaines structures clandestines plus
de la moitié des élèves étaient
officiellement à l'instruction soumis à
l'instruction en famille par ailleurs il
ya au travers de ce dispositif un
message qui est très simple et qui est
d'ailleurs d'actualité lorsque nous
traversons cette crise épidémique et qui
est l'école c'est bon pour les enfants
donc si je devais tout résumé par une
seule phrase je le dirai ainsi l'école
c'est bon pour les enfants
et j'entends trop de discours dans la
société aussi bien aussi de la crise
sanitaire qu'au titre de d enjeu
républicain pour relativiser
l'importance du rôle de l'école
je vais évidemment pas rentrer dans tous
les détails qui vont à la pizza mais
n'oublions jamais cette visée initial
pour tout ce que nous disons parce qu'il
ya toujours des arguments
évidemment pour rechercher plus
d'exception mais ne perdons pas la visée
initial qui est l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant concluent réparé ce point ce
texte est un texte de défense des
valeurs de la république dans chacun de
ses articles
c'est vrai évidemment pour ce qui
concerne l'école mais s'agissant de
l'école il s'agit aussi de défendre les
droits de l'enfant et c'est pourquoi
l'expression d'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant
ray apparaît à plusieurs reprises et
nous en sommes fiers
parce que l'enfant n'appartient à
personne et il est c'est son intérêt
supérieur qui doit être gardée pour
chacune des dispositions que nous
prenons voilà sur le point qui a attiré
le plus l'attention mais bien sûr vous
avez tous à l'esprit les autres mesures
je pense à la notamment à la fermeture
des écoles hors contrat qui ne
correspondent pas aux valeurs de la de
la république est bien entendu
dialogue va continuer sur l'ensemble de
ces points donc merci à tous pour ce
travail de dialogue qui a déjà bien
commencé et qui permet de façonner je
crois ce texte dans un sens qui préserve
les libertés toutes les libertés
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est maintenant à monsieur eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice madame la ministre
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur général
de la messieurs et rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les députés sur avis et
suis fier d'être ici pour vous présenter
ce texte et notre présence à 4
aujourd'hui à 5 demain signant et
témoigne de notre volonté de prêter du
sujet du séparatisme dans sa globalité
d'abord par la transmission des valeurs
républicaines à l'école et pas ailleurs
à l'école ensuite la prévention des
infractions infraction à visées
séparatistes
enfin la sanction pénale bien sûr et
très très brièvement à cet instant je
voudrais vous exposez rapidement les
dispositions porté au nom du ministère
de la justice
d'abord l'article 3 sur lequel nous
avons travaillé avec gérald darmanin
il s'agit du fameux fille jette ce
fichier des auteurs d'infractions
terroristes il nous semble nécessaire
que soit aujourd'hui inclus dans se fige
est les noms des personnes ayant été
condamné pour des infractions en lien
avec des activités
terroristes bien sûr mais également
l'apologie du terrorisme par exemple ce
fichier on va le dire simplement mais
nous nous le développons le moment venu
il était utile lorsque les services de
l'état sont sur le point d'embaucher une
personne et les services de l'état
peuvent ainsi vérifier si j'ose dire que
le loup n'entre pas dans la bergerie
deuxième texte que je défendrai avec
gérald darmanin l'article 4 qui renforce
la protection des personnes qui exercent
des missions de service public contre
ceux qui par des comportements violents
ou menaçant souhaite porter atteinte aux
valeurs de la république
bien sûr les menaces existent déjà dans
le code pénal mais menacé un gardien de
piscine municipale pour obtenir de lui
des choses qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les valeurs de la république notamment
l'égalité hommes femmes
c'est une infraction qui doit être
spécifique et qui doit être
spécifiquement condamné il faut savoir
de quoi on parle il faut savoir ce que
l'on veut ensuite il ya évidemment la la
haine en ligne hélas le ministère de la
justice s'est directement inspiré de la
malheureuse affaire du professeur samuel
pâtit on a regardé comment factuellement
on aurait pu judiciariser plus vite
il y avait véritablement un trou un trou
dans la raquette comme disent les
sportifs c'est une expression
personnellement je déteste mais elle est
utilisée elle a son intérêt elle est
très explicite il ya toute une bulle
mortifère qui se met en place et qui va
aboutir à l'assassinât du malheureux
professeur samuel pâtit
c'est ça que l'on veut
judiciariser et ce texte qui
n'existaient pas or à nous ne le verrons
dans nos débats dont je ne doute pas un
instant qu'ils seront riches une
véritable utilité
le but de cette nouvelle infraction
c'est de sanctionner celui ou celle qui
mettrait en danger
une personne en diffusant des
informations d'identification tenant à
sa vie privée
quand bien même d'ailleurs elle ne
serait pas suivi de conséquences
et naturellement mais nous y reviendrons
nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur
l'élément intentionnel de cette
infraction
d'ailleurs si favorable je le dis à
l'amendement de laëtitia avia sur cette
question nous avons précisé en ce
travail que nous avons déjà en amont
reconduit nous souhaitons préciser bien
sûr que l'auteur ne peut pas ignorer le
risque évidemment alors sur le terrain
probatoire je sais que le parquet de
paris notamment ali mais il ya peut-être
des difficultés oui mais toutes les
infractions sont confrontés à la même
réalité quand on les met en oeuvre c'est
au ministère public de rapporter la
preuve c'est très bien comme ça
et de ce point de vue rien bien sûr ne
doit changer
mais ce texte est important nous le
verrons ensuite il ya je vais très très
vite maintenant l'article 19 qui traite
de ce qu'il convient d'appeler les sites
miroirs cédric au notre collègue viendra
ici soutenir ce texte il ya un certain
nombre d'éléments naturellement
nationaux mais également d' éléments
internationaux et particulièrement
européens qui nous préoccupe et enfin il
ya l'article 20 l'article 20 il permet
d'attraire en comparution immédiate les
haineux du quotidien qui autrefois se
lovait dans la loi de 1881 il n'a pas
été fait pour eux la loi de 1881 été
fait pour protéger les journalistes de
façon très très large
la presse certainement pas pour protéger
ceux qui utilisent aujourd'hui les
réseaux sociaux pour la haine qu il
qui nous qui nous comment dire les
choses de façon triviale qui nous
pourrit la vie aujourd'hui on est tous
d'accord là dessus alors nous avons fait
en sorte après avoir consulté longuement
les journalistes et les syndicats de de
presse les avocats spécialisés en
matière de presse les patrons de presse
nous avons fait en sorte bien sûr de ne
pas toucher à la loi de 1881 qui est
totémique et puis une loi consensuelle
et nous avons créé les dispositions de
la procédure pénale permettant en
réalité d'attraire devant la juridiction
correctionnelle en comparution immédiate
ces noeuds du quotidien pour cela nous
avons mis en place si j'ose dire une
évidemment rappelé que les journalistes
en aucune façon ne pourraient être jugés
dans le cadre de ces dispositions de
procédure pénale et ils sont protégés
parce que sont exclus des nouvelles
dispositions du code de procédure pénale
ce que l'on appelle la responsable est
responsable en cascade c'est une
définition large de journalisme nous
avons évidemment transmis ce projet au
conseil d'état et sur ce point nous
aurons l'occasion de le voir le conseil
d'état bien sûr a validé
c'est cette cette exonération des
journalistes des patrons de presse
nous aurons l'occasion de revenir sur
ces questions voilà moi j'en ai terminé
je voudrais vous dire comme l'ont dit
mais mes collègues que c'est une loi de
liberté et c'est un mot par les temps
qui courent que l'on a plutôt tendance à
complètement dévoyé a dénaturé par
exemple que le fait de nous imposer le
port du masque deviendrait liberticide
alors il ya des spécialistes du
liberticide tous azimuts moi j'affirme
mais nous aurons l'occasion de voir et
c'est notre honneur que de vous le dire
est que de vous le démontrer que cette
loi est une loi de liberté qu'elle est
importante
d'ailleurs chaque fois qu'on rappelle
les valeurs de la république on rappelle
les valeurs de la liberté voilà monsieur
le président ce que trop longuement sans
doute je voulais à rire
en préambule de ce qui nous attend comme
explication bien évidemment plus précise
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
garde des sceaux la parole est
maintenant aux rapporteurs et nous
commençons avec monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur florent boudié merci
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mesdames là la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues vous l'avez dit
monsieur lui de l'intérieur monsieur le
garde des sceaux
c'est un texte de liberté mais c'est un
stand liberté parce que il vise à
protéger nos libertés publiques contre
les dérives qui sont celles des replis
communautaires les dérives dit
séparatistes la liberté de conscience la
liberté de culte
les principes de la république les
principes qui organisent et qui
structure la république et lutter contre
ces phénomènes
partout ils s'introduisent et c'est ce
qui fait d'ailleurs la diversité de ce
texte va dire ça
sa richesse ils s'introduisent par le
biais parfois des services publics
notamment des services publics locaux où
ils s'introduisent parfois par le biais
des associations
des établissements scolaires de l'école
ils s'introduisent parfois vous l'avez
dit monsieur le garde des sceaux par la
haine en ligne et ils s'introduisent
aussi parfois par biais de
l'organisation des cultes et ce sont
l'ensemble de ces éléments que nous
souhaitons pouvoir traiter avec beaucoup
de fermeté et en même temps c'est tout
le travail que nous avons fait au cours
des dernières semaines parce que notre
travail a débuté dès le 17 décembre à
travers une centaine d'auditions à la
fois 34 ici vous l'avez rappelé le seul
président en commission spéciale mais
une soixantaine je crois de vendre
qualité menée par les rapporteurs
thématiques avec la volonté d'un côté
d'objectiver des questions parfois très
techniques et sur lesquels il est
nécessaire de rentrer dans les détails
nous l'avons fait par exemple sur la
question des immeubles de rapport nous
l'avons fait par exemple sur cette
question qui sera central devra
plus tard dans le texte au titre 2
concernant les déclarations de qualité
cultuelle des associations qu'elles
aient le droit existant que modifie en
réalité le projet de loi et nous pouvons
débattre dès lors que de façon
raisonnable si j'ose dire
dès lors que ces questions sont
objectives et et nous avons aussi
cherché et j'en terminerai par là à
regarder ce qui est de l'ordre de
l'effectivité de la loi lorsque
l'orateur adopté lorsqu'elle sera en
application de l'intelligibilité
également d'un certain nombre d'articles
et vous avez monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation souligné un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes parfois qui se sont fait
jour sur notamment la question de
l'instruction en famille et nous
reviendrons très largement sur ces
sujets voilà mes chers collègues dans
quel état d'esprit sont les rapporteurs
de la commission au moment où elle
entame son travail et sa discussion
générale à la fois tenir l'objectif de
fermeté qui est celui porté par le texte
et regarder aussi où sont les points dès
qu'ils y passent que notre conviction je
pense qu'elle est largement partagée
c'est que ce texte ne sera un outil
efficace pour la puissance publique que
si l'ensemble des acteurs concernés ce
que j'ai cités en entame de la brève
intervention s'approprier les outils que
nous allons créer à leur bénéfice et
encore une fois pour conforter les
principes de la république
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
général la parole est maintenant madame
laurence vichnievsky rapporteur sur le
chapitre 2 de ce titre
1 et ce sont les dispositions relatives
aux associations aux services publics
les dispositions relatives aux services
publics bien sûr allez-y madame le
rapport mais si monsieur le président
monsieur le président madame et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
il m'appartient de vous présenter
succinctement les dispositions du
chapitre 1er du projet de loi qui
concerne les services publics et qui
comporte cinq articles
le premier article 1 poursuit deux
objets imposé au délégataire de service
public le respect des principes
d'égalité de neutralité et de laïcité
qui prévalent dans l'administration en
transposant les solutions dégagées par
la jurisprudence renforcer l'effectivité
de ces principes en garantissant aux
personnes publiques des voies de droit
leur permettant de s'assurer de leur
respect les principales questions qui se
poseront à la commission concerneront le
champ précis d'application de ces
principes le deuxième article a pour
objet d'inclure dans le champ de la
procédure dite de déférer accélérer les
actes des collectivités territoriales
qui portent gravement atteinte au
principe de neutralité des services
publics
cette procédure permet aux préfets
d'obtenir du président du tribunal
administratif dans les 48 heures de sa
saisine
une décision de suspension de l'acte
déférer la rédaction de cet article qui
a très largement tenu compte de l'avis
du conseil d'état apparaît désormais
équilibré
l'article 3 relatif aux fillettes
prévoit d'une part d'inscrire de plein
droit dans ce fichier les condamnations
pour infractions terroristes
sauf décision contraire et motivés
d'autre part des lâches d'élargir les
inscriptions aux infractions de
provocation au terrorisme et d' apologie
du terrorisme tout en faisant bénéficier
ces inscriptions élargi d'un régime plus
doux que celui réservé aux condamnations
pour les infractions matériel de
terrorisme je déposerai deux amendements
le premier pour aligner les décisions
d'irresponsabilité pénale sur le régime
général des décisions de condamnation le
second pour imposer aux auteurs de
provocation au terrorisme ou d'apologie
du terrorisme les obligations
déclaratives de domicile et de voyage
pendant 5 ou 3 ans selon qu'ils sont
majeurs ou mineurs
l'article 4 crée un nouveau délit
consistant à user de menaces ou
intimidations contre les agents qui
concourent au service public afin
d'obtenir pour soi-même ou pour autrui
une exemption une application
différencier des règles du service
public jeu proposerait deux amendements
le premier consistant à exclure des
prévisions de l'actuel article 433 3 du
code pénal les faits couverts par ce
nouveau délit le second ayant pour objet
d'autoriser l'administration ou son
délégataire a porté plainte en cas de
commission de ce délit à l'encontre d'un
de ses agents
je crois beaucoup à cette mesure qui est
un bon signal à mon sens de l'article 5
élargi le champ de la protection
fonctionnelle des agents publics
la liste des attaques personnelles
pouvant être signalée à l'employeur est
augmentée des violences physiques et des
menaces je propose deux amendements
le premier pour étendre le champ de la
procédure de signalement à tout acte
d'intimidation par cohérence avec
l'article 4 du projet de loi le second
pour consacré l'engagement de mesures
d'urgence dont les cas les plus graves
même en l'absence de demande formelle de
l'agent je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame le rapporteur et
la parole est maintenant monsieur eric
poulat qui lui est rapporteur sur le
chapitre 2 et de ce titre un et ce sont
bien les dispositions relatives aux
associations cette fois ci c'est vous
avez la parole monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
suivant votre général chers collègues
sans revenir sur ce qui a déjà été
d'évoquer jeu évoqué je souhaite me
concentrer sur le chapitre 2 du titre
premier les dispositions relatives aux
associations comme l'a rappelé le
président de la république dans son
discours des mureaux nos associations
sont un pilier de notre pacte
républicain
j'ajouterai même qu'elle participe à
rendre concrète la promesse républicaine
en encourageant l'émancipation en
protégeant les plus fragiles en faisant
vivre les valeurs et principes qui font
de nous ce que nous sommes mais force
est de constater que l'association
déploie aura été d stratégie assumée
d'endoctrinement ou sur la cible des
séparatismes l'association doivent unir
la nation et non la fracture est elle
s'attache dans la grande majorité à
respecter la république et ses principes
et en retour elles méritent notre
respect c'est protéger les associations
et leur statut si particulier
que de garantir leur liberté les
articles 6 à 8 du projet de loi vise à
garantir le respect des principes
républicains par les associations ainsi
qu'à offrir les moyens la puissance
publique de stopper les agissements
d'une association qui menacerait
gravement l'ordre public et nuirait au
vivre ensemble
tout d'abord si article propose la
création du contrat d'engagement
républicain que s'engageraient à
respecter toute association qui demande
ou qui bénéficient d'une subvention
publique l'objectif et cinq secteurs
sans trace a été rapide à madame la
ministre pas un euro d'argent public ne
doit contribuer au financement
une association qui ne respecteraient
pas les grands principes de notre
république le respect serait également
une nouvelle condition pour l'obtention
d'un agrément particulier 8 propose de
compléter le régime de la dissolution
d'associations dans le but de permettre
une plus grande effectivité de l'action
publique
les articles forme d'un continuant
cohérent ils sont de nature à éviter
qu'une association ne des voix son rôle
civique et citoyen par des agissements
qui porterait atteinte aux principes qui
nous rassemble les articles 9 à 12
constituera un second bloc relatifs au
financement des associations et plus
généralement des organismes sans but
lucratif
il est porté par l'idée que l'argent
public ne doit pas permettre de financer
des activités séparatistes ou contraire
aux principes de la république
pour cela le texte prévoit d'abord le
renforcement des contrôles sur les fonds
de dotation
puis le renforcement des contrôles sur
les organes et de bénéficiaires de dons
ouvrant droit à une réduction d'impôt et
enfin il prévoit la suspension des
avantages fiscaux accordés aux
organismes condamné définitivement pour
des infractions faisant peser une menace
grave sur la société
pour ma part je m'attacherai
principalement à renforcer l'efficacité
du contrat d'engagement un public 1 à
garantir la cohérence de l'action
publique face à des associations qui
s'inscrira en rupture avec nos principes
et à valoriser celles qui font vivre la
république
il ne s'agit aucunement d'avoir de la
défiance vis-à-vis des associations que
je salue pour leur participation à la
tenue de la promesse républicaine mais
bien de combattre ceux qui utilisent ce
bel outil démocratique à des fins
séparatistes ou de les protéger de ceux
ci je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
nous poursuivons avec madame nicole du
bris chirat
rapporteur pour le chapitre iii du titre
premier et ce sont les dispositions
relatives à la dignité humaine merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs rapporteur chers collègues
ce texte dont le thème est respect des
principes de la république a pour objet
le renforcement de la liberté
d'expression de la liberté de
consentement de l'égalité des droits des
personnes ainsi que de la fraternité les
articles 13 à 17 que je rapporte
aujourd'hui sont relatifs à
l'application à l'international de la
réserve héréditaire pour protéger les
droits des héritiers au renforcement de
la lutte contre la polygamie dans le
cadre de la délivrance des titres de
séjour et du versement des pensions de
réversion à l'interdiction des
certificat de virginité au renforcement
de la lutte contre les mariages forcés
et frauduleux l'ensemble de ces articles
relève d'un même chapitre intitulé
dispositions relatives à la dignité de
la personne humaine
pour ma part je considère comme plus
cohérent avec le contenu des articles de
faire référence au respect des droits
des personnes et à l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes
j'ai déposé un amendement allant dans ce
sens par ailleurs s'agissant des
dispositions relatives à la lutte contre
la polygamie il m'apparaît essentiel
qu'un accompagnement soit prévu pour les
conjointes des ressortissants en état de
polygamie
dès lors que leur titre de séjour
l'aurait retirer automatiquement en même
temps que celui de leurs conjoints les
pouces subit en effet la violence de la
polygamie
c'est pourquoi j'ai déposé un amendement
qui prévoit que la situation du conjoint
d'anne étrangers dont le titre de séjour
est retiré pour polygamie fait l'objet
d'un examen individuel
il faut aussi que l'association soit
très mobilisés pour accompagner ces
femmes souvent aux victimes collatérales
ou même titre que celles qui se verront
retirer leur pension de reversions
s'agissant de ces pensions de réversion
il apparaît indispensable que l'ensemble
des conventions internationales qui
autorise la pension de reversions
partagé entre toutes les épouses soient
renégociés
pour ce qui concerne l'interdiction des
certificat de virginité
je suis très favorable ce que
l'entourage de jeu
femmes qui la pousse à l'entente a
demandé ce certificat de virginité
puisse également faire l'objet de
poursuites pénales
aussi je vous souhaite vous indiquer qu
aujourd'hui nous poursuivons notre
travail avec les ministres concernés
pour aboutir à une rédaction plus
adaptées plus pertinente d'un amendement
allant dans ce sens enfin pour ce qui
concerne les mariages frauduleux et
forcé il m'apparaît que pour lutter
efficacement contre ces mariages
il est impératif d'accompagner les
officiers d'état civil afin qu'ils
puissent disposer d'outils comme un tram
pour conduire l'entretien en couple puis
individuellement
ceci afin de leur permettre de détecter
des signes de non consentement d'une des
personnes concernées nous souhaitons
aborder ces discussions dans un esprit
constructif et positif
je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la rapporteure la parole est
maintenant madame laetitia avia
rapporteur pour le chapitre iv du titre
1 et qui portent notamment sur la lutte
contre la haine en libye pardoux
merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues assurer le respect des
principes de la république est un combat
qui doit être mené en tout lieu et ce y
compris l'espace numérique
c'est l'objet du chapitre 4 de ce projet
de loi nous avons pu le constater lors
des auditions
tous nos interlocuteurs que ce soient
les représentants des cultes des
courants philosophiques des sociologues
les historiens les associations d'élus
tous s'accordent sur le besoin de
réguler internet et lutter contre les
dérives sur les réseaux sociaux
tout d'abord lutter contre
l'exacerbation des discours de haine
tenus par des personnes qui cachait
derrière un écran et des pseudonymes
d'un des coups de canifs quotidien à
notre pacte républicain
lutter contre internet comme un outil de
facilité pour tous ceux qui pour nuire à
quelqu'un peuvent lancer de vraies fatwa
numérique impunément et nous avons
forcément aujourd'hui une pensée très
forte pour semelle paty et ses proches
enfin lutter contre internet comme un
lieu de radicalisation en particulier
d'une jeunesse d'autant plus une érable
stratégie d'endoctrinement et
d'embrigadement numérique c'est ont tous
ces aspects que nous devons agir
sanctionner les pourvoyeurs de m
réguler les plateformes numériques
protéger chacun chacune y compris dans
l'espace numérique
le texte proposé par le gouvernement
comporte trois dispositifs un nouveau
délit de mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui par la divulgation
d'informations personnelles sur internet
qui a été présenté par le garde des
sceaux se délient nous dit qu'on ne peut
pas mettre une cible impunément dans le
dos de quelqu'un se délient répondra
aussi au calvaire que vivent de nombreux
jeunes filles et des jeunes lgbt qui
font de gré de ses pratiques
régulièrement il nous faudra avancer sur
des éléments de caractérisation de cd de
ce délit vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre nous ferons une proposition en
ce sens le second dispositif vise à
mieux lutter contre les sites miroirs
répliquant des sites qui ont été
interdits par la justice des sites
extrémistes souvent tenus par des
racistes antisémites homophobes
suprémacistes blancs dont je tairai le
nom ici enfin pour lutter contre
l'impunité
il faut des procédures rapides adapté
autant numérique et je salue la
proposition de faire passer en
comparution immédiate
les pourvoyeurs de haine qui ne relève
aucunement des protections du à la
presse pour que le dispositif soit
complet ne pouvons pas faire l'impasse
sur la régulation des plateformes off
quels sont les principaux outils de ces
dérives
c'est pourquoi avec le gouvernement nous
avons déposé un amendement visant à
donner des obligations de diligence et
de transparence aux plateformes sous la
supervision du cfa
l'actualité récente nous rappelle que
les plateformes ne peuvent plus
détourner le regard
nous aussi que doivent être encadrés par
des lois c'est ce que nous vous
proposons ici
sous l'impulsion de la commission
européenne voici monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ce que nous vous
proposons pour lutter contre les dérives
sur internet ne seront peut-être pas
d'accord sur tous les moyens à mettre en
oeuvre mais j'espère que nous
partagerons tous l'urgence et la
nécessité d'agir
nous le devons à sanaa le pâtis à millas
à nice provence et à tant d'autres
victimes quotidiennes de cette haine
merci beaucoup madame la rapporteure
nous poursuivons maintenant avec madame
anne brunier rats rapporteur pour le
chapitre 5 du
ti train et ce sont les dispositions
relatives à l'éducation monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
chers collègues j'ai l'honneur d'être
rapporteur des articles relatifs à
l'éducation et aux sports j'ai mené et
plus d'une vingtaine d'auditions
thématiques qui m'ont montré mais je
n'en doutais pas l'importance de ces
sujets pour de nombreux français bien
sûr pour ceux qui sont directement
concernés dans leur vie quotidienne mais
également beaucoup plus largement la
présence de ces dispositions dans ce
projet de loi a tout son sens
compte tenu également de leur étroite
relation avec la transmission des
principes de la république auquel nous
sommes attachés
le projet de loi comprend quatre grandes
dispositions dans les cinq articles de
ce chapitre l'article 21 a pour objet
d'encadrer l'instruction en famille pour
la prémunir contre certaines dérives qui
ont pu être observés il s'agit en
l'entourant d'un cadre plus précis de
garantir qu'elle s'exerce dans des
conditions permettant la qualité de
l'instruction de l'enfant mais surtout
le respect son intérêt supérieur qui
doit primer en toutes circonstances les
articles 22 et 23 renforce le contrôle
des établissements privés d'enseignement
hors contrat notamment s'agissant de
leur financement et de leurs personnels
là encore pour veiller à la sécurité des
élèves et à la qualité de l'enseignement
qui leur est dispensée l'article 24
conditionne la passation du contrat avec
l'état une vérification plus approfondie
de la capacité de l'établissement privé
à dispenser un enseignement conforme ou
pas référence au programme de
l'enseignement public
enfin l'article 25 modifie le cadre
d'exercices des associations sportives
et de leur fédération pour garantir le
plein respect et la promotion de
l'éthique du sport
nous reviendrons dans les débats plus en
détail sur les amendements des uns et
des autres mais je souhaite vous exposer
ce que se présenterai en particulier
s'agissant de l'instruction en famille
en premier lieu indiquerait
explicitement que l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant doit être le motif qui prime
sur tous les autres
et je supprimerai la mention relative
aux convictions religieuses
philosophiques ou politiques des parents
en second lieu je préciserai que dans
certains cas l'autorisation pourra être
délivrée pour une durée supérieure à un
an
j'indique aurait également de manière
claire que le silence de
l'administration vaut accord à l'issue
d'un délai de deux mois
j'apporterai des précisions sur
différents aspects pour garantir le
caractère opérationnel du nouveau
dispositif en simple je proposerai
plusieurs mesures pour lutter contre la
déscolarisation et les rythmes scolaires
qui affectent en particulier les enfants
instruits en famille ou dans des
établissements hors contrat car ils
peuvent aujourd'hui sortir du radar de
l'état et sont parfois dans des
situations préoccupantes
mes chers collègues je forme le voeu que
nous parviendrons par nos débats un
dispositif véritablement équilibré qui
nous permettra d'assurer la pleine prise
en compte des droits de l'enfant ce qui
doit être notre boussole
s'agissant du sport ne pourront
également enrichir le texte pour donner
aux associations et aux fédérations
sportives la place qu'elle souhaite
prendre et que pour certaines elles
assument déjà en matière de promotion
des principes républicains ainsi que de
protection des sportifs dont de nombreux
mineurs mes chers collègues je vous
remercie pour votre attention si merci
beaucoup
madame la rapporteure la parole est
maintenant à monsieur sacha oublier
rapporteur pour le chapitre 2 du titre
ii du titre iii du titre iv qui concerne
la préservation de l'ordre public
merci monsieur le président la laïcité
c'est d'abord la liberté et beaucoup
d'entre vous l'ont dit et celle de
croire de ne pas croire de pratiquer ou
de ne pas le faire et si l'on recherche
outre dans les zi fameux les sources de
cette laïcité on peut aussi la voir dans
les phrases ou les propos de nicolas de
condorcet qui indiquait que nous ne
demandons pas aux gens de penser comme
nous mais qu'ils apprennent à penser par
eux-mêmes ou du moins qu'on puisse leur
garantir de penser par eux-mêmes c'est
l'esprit des lois de 1905 un esprit
libéral qui a guidé les travaux
d'investissement riant et les difficiles
et libérale ou si on l'appelle ainsi
c'est parce que tout ce qui n'est pas
interdit est par principe autorisée
et ce qui est interdit les dans la
poursuite d'un intérêt d'un objectif
d'intérêt général qui est la sauvegarde
de l'ordre public libéral donc la
laïcité mais également contractuels et
le texte comporte des éléments le
contrat d'engagement républicain qui
rappelle cette nature contractuelle pour
filer la métaphore c'est donc au droit
des contrats que j'emprunterai un
lexique pour présenter les dispositions
qui sont celles de la police des cultes
d'abord les clauses noir ceux qui
luttent contre le terrorisme de textes
non content or porte pas directement
puisque ces dispositions ont été réglés
soit par la loi de 1955 de l'état
d'urgence soit encore par la loi
sécurité intérieure et lutte contre le
terrorisme que nous avons adoptée au
début du quinquennat
ensuite les clauses dites blanches
celles qui sont les plus libérales qui
garantissent le régime et qui prévoit
tout de moi c'est toutefois certaines
dispositions avec un régime déclaratoire
notamment sur les obligations
administratives ou comptables nouvelle
qui pourrait peser sur les associations
celle de certifier leurs comptes ou de
faire figurer dans un conte différencier
séparer les financements provenant
étrangers ou d'établir encore une liste
de lieux de culte avec naturellement des
infractions associées lorsque ça n'est
pas fait ou encore le droit d'opposition
qui est donnée à l'administration pour
s'opposer à les financements étrangers
le but recherché c'est celui là
transparence et c'est dans cette optique
qu'un pouvoir nous est donné à trac fort
les zones grises et c'est là la
principale innovation de ce texte
d'abord pour moderniser les dispositions
la loi de 1905 devenu obsolète pour
tenir les prêcheurs de haine
éloigné des lieux de culte et des
associations qui en ont la charge pour
prescrire des sanctions efficace et
proportionnée en conservant l'essentiel
de cette construction et à la lumière
des auditions que nous avons conduite je
souhaite que nous discutions de la
possibilité d'élargir le contrôle des
financements étrangers aux associations
relevant de la loi de 1901
lorsque ces financements proviennent
d'états tiers à l'union européenne
je souhaite que nous puissions aligner
les peines prévues au titre de la police
des cultes en cas d'incitation à la
haine ou la violence sur celle de la loi
de 1881 sur la liberté de la presse
je crois qu'il en va de la clarté de la
police comme l'indiquent le conseil
d'état dans son habit souhaite envisager
le prononcer plus systématique de la
peine complémentaire d'interdiction de
paraître dans les
culte lorsque ces infractions ont été
commises en lien avec les cultes de
fixer à trois mois d'interdiction la
fermeture des lieux de culte qui serait
non renouvelables sauf en cas d'éléments
nouveaux et c'est une fermeture
administrative qui est prévue en
décalque de la doua site et enfin de
préciser le régime d'opposition en
protégeant les collaborateurs des
banques qui auront l'exercer d'exonérer
la responsabilité des établissements
puisqu'ils le font sur ordre de
l'administration et de garantir l'effet
qu'il l'effectivité du droit nouveaux
employés en ce blocage pour les chèques
ou les paiements par cartes bancaires de
tout ça nous discuterons ensemble
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapport merci
beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
nous enchaînons maintenant avec les
orateurs de groupe
et là je passe la parole à monsieur
francis ce choix qui est l'orateur du
groupe la république en marche pour un
temps de parole maximale de 5 minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
messieurs les ministres à mon tour de
saluer le président de rugy le
rapporteur général florent boudié il
rapporte heureux et rapporteur
l'administration notre assemblée pour
avoir réussi dans un laps de temps
contraint à recueillir pendant des
dizaines d'heures d'audition les avis
d'un spectre très large d'acteurs de
personnalités qui ont beaucoup plus
tolérer les législateurs que nous sommes
dans la diversité de leurs opinions et
de leurs propositions nul n'a remis en
cause la nécessité de légiférer pour
conforter les principes de notre
république
cette loi répond également à une attente
dans le pays malgré le contexte
sanitaire qui obsède à juste titre nos
concitoyens tous montrent qu'ils sont
très inquiets face au terrorisme
islamiste et aux menaces de dislocation
de notre communauté nationale
nous sommes moins de quatre mois après
que le président de la république a au
bureau fixé le cap face à l'une des
principales menaces qui pèsent sur la
paix civile qui opprime et qui tuent en
france en europe et dans le monde
quelques jours plus tard le terrorisme a
décapité samuel pâtit
pour avoir simplement fait sans devoir
d'éducateur liberté de conscience
les parties civiles du procès charlie
hebdo ont fait l'objet de menaces de
mort nice a de nouveau été durement
affecté vienne la capitale de l'autriche
a été frappé et régulièrement des états
d'afrique et d'asie centrale musulmans
subissent des massacres de masse
perpétrés par les islamistes plus
insidieusement
combien d'enseignants d'élus de
policiers de gendarmes de pompiers de
médecins de femmes vivent la boule au
ventre en se demandant s'ils ne vont pas
devoir s'excuser de vivre en république
par la laïcité qui est la quintessence
de la liberté à travers la complexité et
l'extrême sensibilité des sujets qu'il
traite
ne perdons donc jamais de vue que cette
loi est faite pour armer
démocratiquement légalement tous ceux
qui auront à la mettre en oeuvre
car comme cela a déjà été dit sa
réussite tiendra toute entière dans son
exécution volontaire elle va permettre à
tous les acteurs des services publics et
à ce qu'ils aient concours de mieux
faire vivre le principe fondateur de
notre république le respect de la
laïcité de l'égalité et de la neutralité
de l'état à travers le contrat
d'engagement républicain elle fournit
l'occasion aux élus aux associations aux
administrations publiques de construire
ensemble la laïcité du quotidien et
d'exprimer clairement ce que son nom
règles de vie commune dans une société
démocratique et l'égalité pour reprendre
cette belle expression de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme de 1953
elle s'attaque très volontairement au
déferlement de haine et de harcèlement
en ligne comme aux ide jade elle fait
honneur à notre identité de patrie des
droits de l'homme en réprimant les
phénomène d'emprise et les pratiques
attentatoires à l'intégrité et à la
dignité des personnes
elle donne des moyens nouveaux occultes
et à la justice de combattre l'emprise
du séparatisme sur des associations
cultuelles et culturelles
elle remet l'école pour tous les enfants
au coeur du village
dans le respect des libertés
fondamentales des familles mais en
agissant contre les zones d'ombré des
écoles au contrat et contre la
déscolarisation d'enfants à des fins
séparatistes qui portent atteinte à
leurs intérêts supérieurs nous allons
enrichir ce projet de loi c'est notre
rôle de législateur
je pense en particulier à la nécessité
de renforcer la protection et
l'accompagnement des agents publics
les personnels de l'éducation en premier
lieu dans leur mission je pense
également à l'impérieuse nécessité de
mettre en place un vaste programme de
formation aux principes républicains et
à la laïcité de tous les agents publics
et de tous les acteurs associatifs
si l'adhésion à la république qui est la
laïcité a perdu du terrain
reconnaissons le face à ceux qui se sont
promis de disloquer la cité française
c'est bien sûr parce que grandit le
sentiment d'impuissance à s'attaquer à
la racine des multiples et d'égalité et
des discriminations qui minent l'avenir
de millions de citoyens et qui ronge des
territoires entiers et nous aurons sans
doute besoin de charpentes et plus
solidement les politiques de citoyenneté
de lutte contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme de prévention de la
radicalisation de lutte contre les
ghettos et pour l'engagement citoyen et
l'intégration mais c'est tout autant
parce qu'au fil du temps nous avons
cessé de faire de l'adhésion à une
communauté de destin au respect de ces
principes
un sujet cardinal de mobilisation
populaire que notre socle c'est
fragiliser alors face à des infos civ
identitaire très structuré
idéologiquement et politiquement la
république doit elle même retrouvée des
appuis solides
faisons en sorte et faisons en sorte
très largement que cette loi y
contribuer
merci beaucoup monsieur le député la
parole est maintenant pour le groupe
l'est républicain
tout d'abord à madame annie genevard
puis à monsieur eric diard puisque le
groupe l'est républicain a souhaité sand
et son temps de parole en deux
madame la députée vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mon
intervention sera brève d'autant que
nous partageons ce temps de parole avec
eric diard quelques mots tout d'abord
compte revenir sur les nombreuses
auditions que nous avons fait quasiment
toutes ont souligné l'urgence dans
laquelle se trouve notre pays confrontés
à un danger majeur comme notre histoire
a pu en connaître
même si celui ci est d'une nature
particulièrement grave dans l'islamisme
radical s'est enracinée au point de
menacer les principes mêmes de notre
république que ce projet de loi
affirment vouloir conforter cette
volonté les républiques à la partage et
nous entendons y apporter notre
contribution
d'abord je voudrais rappeler qu'à
l'assemblée il n'y a pas de débat
interdit nous entendons bien introduire
dans la discussion parlementaire des
sujets comme celui du voile dont la
propagation exponentielle vise à imposer
une autre norme sociale que l'immense
majorité des femmes de notre pays refuse
la question migratoire en est une autre
vous n'en voulez pas dans ce débat
pourtant nul ne peut raisonnablement
nier qu'elle a un lien étroit avec la
propagation de cette idéologie ces
questions viendront nous sommes
particulièrement choqués par l' usage
que nous jugeons politique de l'article
je rappelle que la rédaction actuelle de
l'article 45 date de 2008 à l'initiative
du président nicolas sarkozy et consacre
le lien même indirect même indirect
entre l'amendement et le texte pour nous
ce texte ne va pas assez loin
les propositions utiles nous les
approuveront celle que nous jugeons trop
faible nous les amènerons quant à celle
que nous jugeons mauvaise
nous les combattrons car contrairement à
ce que certains membres du gouvernement
ont pu déclarer récemment là et bien
l'essence de notre fonction je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame la députée la
parole est donc maintenant monsieur eric
diard toujours pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs les ministres
madame monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues le projet de loi que nous
discutons aujourd'hui vise à conforter
le respect des principes républicains
ce projet s'est fait attendre peut-être
trop attendre ça fait longtemps que
différents groupes cherchent à faire
vaciller malheureusement notre
république de l'intérieur et qu'à chaque
fois nous apportons des réponses au coup
par coup
en réaction à l'actualité dès le début
du mandat la loi sur la sécurité
intérieure et la lutte contre le
terrorisme et l occasion de prendre le
problème de la radicalisation à bras le
corps il y a un an en janvier 2020 était
déposé la proposition de loi sécurité
globale que nous avons adoptée en
première lecture il ya deux mois
là encore nous avions l'occasion d'y
insérer des dispositions relatives à la
lutte contre la radicalisation
mais là encore nous opposer que ça
n'était pas le sujet du texte étudié
alors que la radicalisation et un des
ferments du terrorisme en février 2020
le président république dans son
discours mulhouse par les jeux le site
de protéger des libertés contre le
séparatisme islamistes il a fallu
évidemment attendre le discours des
mureaux en octobre pour enfin avoir une
date à laquelle on pourrait discuter de
ce projet de loi est attendu aujourd'hui
nous examinons ce texte
malheureusement il commence à rassembler
une série de renoncement
les articles sur la mixité sociale ont
été supprimés avant projet il n'y a pas
non plus d'articles pour reprendre en
main les territoires dits oubliés de la
république conformément au discours du
président aux mureaux le gouvernement
également renoncé à l'idée d'obliger les
associations gérant lieu de culte à
s'inscrire dans les régimes spécifiques
des 3905 et le rapporteur général a même
précisé en audition vendredi dernier que
cette loi ne traitait pas de
radicalisation
or comment traiter le séparatisme en
occultant la radicalisation
enfin certains services publics ne font
l'objet d'aucun article dans ce texte je
pense notamment au séparatisme dans les
hôpitaux les universités et les prisons
sur le président vous avez quand même eu
une vision restrictive de l'article 45
de la constitution et je prendrai un
exemple le délai voc développement des
enquêtes administratives pour certains
secteurs publics ont toutes été rejetées
même celles concernant l'éducation alors
que l'éducation c'est un chapitre
justement de ce texte est que ces
enquêtes ont fait l'objet de
préconisations temps dans le rapport que
j'ai fait avec mon collègue éric
pouilles
que dans le rapport de la commission
d'amm d' enquête du rapporteur général
mes chers collègues je pense que nous
devons profiter de ces débats pour
enrichir le texte afin de rendre
pleinement efficace et de le rendre
pleinement efficace contre les menaces
qui pèsent sur notre république
je conclurai en soulignant à ceux qui
lèvent déjà les boucliers contre des
restrictions de nos libertés qu'il faut
bien garder en tête bien garder en tête
que dans ce pays il ya des personnes qui
usent justement de nos libertés pour
nous en priver
merci mon cher collègue la parole est
maintenant madame isabelle florennes
pour le groupe modem
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues
notre commission débute aujourd'hui
l'examen du projet de loi renforçant et
respect des principes de la république
le titre même de l'étendue de ce que
nous avons à reconquérir et qu'il ne
dépendra pas seulement loin s'en faut de
cette loi dire qu'il faut respecter des
principes c'est reconnaître
implicitement leur affaiblissement s'est
aussi rappelé que la république comme la
démocratie doit constamment avoir le
souci de sa propre pédagogie pour
convaincre plutôt que contraindre pour
faire adhérer plutôt que de forcer cette
recherche du plébiscite de tous les
jours est un défi permanent pour un
régime politique qui passe au plus haut
de son ambition la liberté et l'égalité
de tous ses concitoyens et qui ne tient
que parce qu'il se donne les moyens
d'accéder à cet idéal
sinon n'a pas conscience de la fragilité
de cet édifice démocratique et
républicain on ne peut mesurer les
forces qui le menace
il faut pourtant se rappeler que la
démocratie est une exception dans la
longue histoire des hommes au premier
rang de ces principes il en est un qui à
notre sens et dessus de tous les autres
la séparation du temporel et du
spirituel résumé dans cette simple
phrase
la loi protège la foi et l'absence de
fois mais la foi ne peut ne fait pas la
loi
or ce principe est depuis trop
nombreuses années attaqué par ceux qui
n'ont d'autre but que celui d'imposer
leur loi à une société démocratique
ces menaces nous les connaissons
la radicalité religieuse l'intégrisme en
particulier le communautarisme qui en
découlent et qui s'affranchit
progressivement de toutes les règles
minimales de la vie en société le rejet
des lois républicaines
l'affaiblissement de l'école de la
liberté associative tout cela amplifié
par la caisse de résonance offertes par
les réseaux sociaux notre pays ne
connaît que trop ces déchirements et la
république doit tenir ferme sur ses
principes c'est déjà ce qu'affirmait en
2003 la commission stasi au sujet de la
laïcité tenir ferme
ce n'est pas se laisser illusionner par
ceux qui affirment que la laïcité serait
discriminante un outil du pouvoir pour
limiter la volonté ou la liberté voire
une arme tournée contre une partie de la
population c'est tout le contraire
il y à une réponse ferme à apporter et
ce projet de loi y contribuer par de
nombreuses mesures que nous aurons
largement le temps de discuter mais il
ya une autre réponse tout aussi
essentielle celle de la promesse
républicaine qui offre à chacun et à
chacune
les moyens de son propre avenir
tout au long de nos débats je souhaite
que nous ne perdions pas de vue cette
double obligation donner les moyens la
république de se défendre et permettre à
tous
la réalisation de cet idéal cela passera
notamment par l'accompagnement des élus
locaux et des collectivités qui sont
confrontés très directement et
quotidiennement aux pratiques
séparatistes et qui se trouvent souvent
démunis pour lutter contre elle de même
nous devons veiller au renforcement des
principes contenus dans la loi de 1905
relative au fonctionnement et aux
activités des associations cultuelles et
lieux de culte
nous devons aussi étendre le principe de
neutralité qui en de multiples endroits
et mis à mal à notre sens nous devons
avancer sur deux points au moins
l'obligation pour l'administration
lorsque cette dernière a connaissance de
faits de menaces de violences ou d'actes
d'intimidation à l'égard d'un de ses
agents de porter plainte
l'obligation pour les associations aussi
bénéficiant d'une ope c'est d'une
subvention publique de s'engager à
promouvoir les principes énoncés dans le
contrat d'engagement républicain et
l'obligation pour l'intégralité de leurs
membres bénévoles ou non de respecter le
principe de neutralité
lorsque leurs activités s'adressent à
des mineurs plus spécifiquement sur
l'instruction à domicile nous proposons
un régime d'autorisation adossé à une
déclaration préalable qui aurait l
avantage de protéger cette liberté tout
en renforçant le suivi des enfants en
isf garantissant ainsi la qualité de
l'enseignement
s'agissant enfin de la haine en ligne
nous proposerons la réécriture de
l'article 18 ans précise en précisant
les catégories juridiques visé et en
élargissant le dispositif aux mineurs
premières victimes des campagnes de
harcèlement sur internet ainsi que le
blocage des sites des miroirs qui relaie
des contenus haineux ou faisant
l'apologie du terrorisme
le groupe démocrate se positionne donc
dans ce débat avec la ferme intention de
rappeler que nous devons collectivement
uvrer pour trouver les voies et les
moyens de la concorde nationale qu'il
n'y a pas d'autre issue que celle qui
fait de la loi la même pour tous et que
nous devons veiller à faire en sorte de
porter au plus haut la liberté la
conscience et la responsabilité de
chacun d'entre nous
merci merci beaucoup madame la députée
la parole m m
madame cécile untermaier pour le groupe
socialiste
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues au nom du groupe
socialiste je ferai trois observations
une observation de forme déjà c'est un
texte qui touche à toutes nos libertés
fondamentales et nos droits garantis par
la constitution cela a été dit à
plusieurs reprises et pourtant ce texte
comporte une étude d'impact très
sommaire qui complique vraiment l'
approche objective que nous devons avoir
les dispositions projeter comme le
constate d'ailleurs le conseil
et ce n'est pas le court exposé des
motifs qui va éclairer autant qu'il le
faudrait le législateur la précipitation
continue encore ici avec une procédure
accélérée et un temps programmé en
séance publique
vous le savez plusieurs années ont été
nécessaires pour les députés d'alleurs
pour constituer les oeuvres législatives
que nous revisitons ce projet de loi
exigeant réalité une très grande
attention une très grande prudence pour
trouver les bons équilibres
nous ne sommes pas convaincus que ceux
ci soient trouvées s'agissant en
particulier de la liberté d'association
et de la liberté de culte
une remarque de fond l'effroyable
assassinat de samuel patiner pas hélas
le premier crime commis en france au nom
d'un fondamentalisme islamiste qui n'est
pas la religion musulmane
il s'inscrit dans un engrenage de
barbarie que nous combattons avec le
rappel constant que ces actes d'une
violence insoutenable ne devront pas et
ne pourront pas avoir raison de nos
modes de vie et de nos libertés
mais au contraire les conforter ainsi
respecter les principes de la république
ne se négocie pas ne peut faire l'objet
d'un contrat ou sur plus limité dans le
texte à celles et ceux du monde
associatif qui sollicite une subvention
publique respecter les principes de la
république ainsi que le prétend ce texte
avant toute autorité
c'est d'abord faire vivre une république
indivisible laïque démocratique et
sociale
une république qui lutte contre les
discriminations organise la mixité
sociale l école et dans l'habitat l'égal
accès aux soins et à la culture
rien n'est dit à ce sujet dans ce texte
ma troisième remarque notre groupe sera
au soutien de certaines dispositions de
ce texte mais nous avons de réels doutes
d'une manière générale sur son
efficacité et son utilité dans son
ensemble fallait-il modifier les lois de
1901 1905 et 1907
fallait-il ajouter des incriminations
pénales
peut-être mais il s'agit désormais de
s'interroger plus que sur le
renforcement de l'arsenal pénal sur
l'efficacité des infractions dénoncées
comment faire que les dépôts de plainte
des victimes permettent à celle ci
d'être rapidement protéger des violences
ou des menaces qu'elle dénonce
dans son avis le conseil d'état fait
appel à la prudence au constat que les
libertés d'expression d'opinion de culte
sont convoqués et que les multiples
contraintes nouvelles sont de nature à
remettre en question l'équilibré
législatif il en est par exemple de
l'article 6 et du contrat d'engagement
républicains ou des articles 27 et 33
nous ne soutiendrons pas des contraintes
inutiles
dès lors qu'elles sont sans effet sur
les deux logis mortifère que nous
combattons et constitue finalement une
intrusion dans une sphère de liberté en
conclusion je dirais que il manque les
mesures positives ou en miroir des
dispositions de contrôle qui font naître
un certain moment le soupçon et
l'inquiétude trop d'amendements
corrigeant ainsi le texte ont été
rejetées sur la base de l'article 45
cela a été dit à plusieurs reprises
nous pensons nous en particulier à la
question de la formation à la
citoyenneté
nous pensons aussi à la déradicalisation
dans les prisons nous pensons aussi à la
question de la mixité sociale dans
l'habitat et dans l'école et la demande
que nous faisions d'un rapport cela a
été rejeté
ce dont la république a le plus besoin
c'est une politique généreuse et
constante pour faire vivre ces valeurs
c'est donc à l'aune de ces exigences que
nous des patrons de ce texte je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame la députée la
parole est maintenant monsieur
christophe euzet pour le groupe agir
ensemble
merci monsieur le président monsieur
madame des ministres ce rapporteur
général mesdames messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues je garde des
sceaux souligné il ya un instant le
nombre élevé de ministres autour de
cette table pour signifier l'importance
du texte que nous avons à travailler
aujourd'hui nous avons le sentiment
groupe agir ensemble effectivement il
s'agit d'un texte d'un texte important
important d'abord dans le plat de la
mandature puisqu'il vient à l'issue d'un
certain nombre de textes en matière
éducative en matière de rénovation
urbaine en matière de réforme de la
justice en matière encore de de police
et qui précède un volet de mixité
sociale qui viendra dans le cadre du
projet de loi 4d porté par la mise
jacqueline jacqueline gourault mais
c'est surtout un texte important parce
que il fait pas est fait référence bien
sûr à la cohésion de notre pays à notre
un autre avenir collectif et qu'ils
portent bien évidemment sur un sujet
éminemment sensible éminemment sensible
ce qu'est le risque le risque
séparatistes c'est à dire le danger
qu'une partie de la communauté sant
nationale se séparent d'elle pour se
choisir un destin un destin alternatif
c'est un sujet périlleux sur lequel
s'impose la nécessité d'un débat digne
et responsable
c'est un sujet grave également dans
lequel le déni ou l'inertie ne rendrait
pas service au pays et dans lequel
l'exagération répressive le remettrait
en cause finalement à quoi nous sommes
tous et toutes attachées ici à savoir la
démocratie libérale sociale et son état
de droit et il en va de la liberté de
notre de nos compatriotes
quelle que soit leur religion à qui nous
avons le devoir d'assurer la garantie de
principe de principes républicains
il fallait trouver des solutions fernand
il fallait procéder avec discernement
il fallait être sans jeu de mots
fermement raisonnable nous avons le
sentiment que c'est un texte audacieux
qui n'a pas de précédent que c'est un
texte équilibré et proportionnée car il
le fait sans perdre de vue
d'abord ce qu'est la que c'est la
société et sa cohésion qui est en jeu et
que c'est aussi la protection des
libertés fondamentales de nos
compatriotes dont il est question ici
est que seul le principe de laïcité peut
garantir
alors pour revenir sur le contenu du
texte sans être trop long et est
respecté le délai qui met un parti la
question de la neutralité du service
public et toutes les mesures qui
concernent les dérives des organismes de
droit privé chargées d'une mission de
service public nous paraît tout à fait
de bon aloi et traités avec discernement
tout ce qui concerne la pub
l'encadrement des activités associatives
et notamment tout ce qui concerne les
accès aux dotations publiques et le
contrat d'engagement républicains nous
paraît également nécessaire et
dispositions relatives à la dignité de
la personne humaine
pareillement nous paraissent tout à fait
tout à fait indispensable de la même
façon que le débat qui s'ouvre en
matière d'éducation qui suggère une
réflexion sérieuse sensible mais nous
paraît bien avancée va également dans le
bon sens par ailleurs le fait de
combattre la haine en ligne suite au
drame que nous avons tous et toutes
revues et et commenté nous paraît tout à
fait tout à fait pertinent est
souhaitable compte tenu du déferlement
de haine auxquels fait face notre notre
société désormais sur ses réseaux
numériques sur cette vie tristement
virtuel
enfin le financement et la police des
cultes ont fait l'objet de dispositions
que nous considérons également comme
importante est louable
alors le groupe 1 agir ensemble on est
globalement très favorable à ce projet
de à ce projet de loi il apportera sur
un certain nombre de points des
propositions d'amendements ce parfois un
petit peu plus répressives de façon à
rendre les dispositions dissuasives
parfois plus préventive notamment
renforcé en renforçant la dimension
formation qui nous paraît tout aussi
indispensable à la cohésion nationale
il préservera quoi qu'il en soit la
liberté de chacun de ses membres de se
déterminer sur un certain nombre de
points qui a la marge pourrait faire
débat il laissera donc à chacun le choix
de décider d'amender selon ses
convictions un profonde mais le groupe
agir ensemble compte tenu de la
difficulté de la sensibilité toute
particulière du débat s'attachera
également et enfin par l'intermédiaire
de ses deux porte voix que seront pierre
yves bournazel et et moi même a
contribué à la dignité d'un débat majeur
pour le pays durant lequel nous serons
probablement très regardé écouté et à
l'issue duquel sans aucun doute évaluer
collectivement je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le député la
parole est maintenant à monsieur jean
christophe lagarde président du groupe
u10
merci monsieur le président madame et
messieurs les miches collègues nous
soutenons globalement les objectifs de
ce projet de loi
toutefois en plusieurs occasions et on
verra au cours des amendements demandant
si les dispositifs envisagés sont
opérationnels s'ils seront offert ans
ils seront efficaces ou s'il ne rate pas
la cible visée la discours du président
de la république aux mureaux avait fait
on doit leur en donner acte un
diagnostic lucide de ce qui a favorisé
la propagation de mener séparatiste même
si le terme a disparu dans le texte sur
notre pays de mener séparatistes qui
trouve comme litière les échecs de la
république les échecs en matière
d'éducation léger c'est qu'en matière
d'intégration les échecs en matière
d'accompagnement social ou de
réinsertion sociale et ce n'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau mais en faire
le constat lucide devrait conduire dans
ce texte a accompagné justement la
destruction de la litière faire en sorte
que le terreau fertile sur lequel
poussent les intégrismes et
principalement l'islamisme puisse
disparaître ce n'est pas le cas et je
souhaite au nom de notre groupe le
regretter on peut nous annoncer un futur
texte dans l'encombrement législatif qui
est le nôtre on peut plus que douter que
ce texte voit le jour un jour en tout
cas au cours de cette législature
deuxième observation il y à là dedans
nombre de dispositifs que nous pouvons
souvenir je pense par exemple à la
nécessité de la neutralité du service
public à la protection des agents
publics à et c'est une part importante
du texte la meilleure observation la
meilleure lutte contre des détours
financiers qui ne sont pas acceptables
et si bien sûr ce texte à vocation comme
ses prédécesseurs à s'appliquer à
l'ensemble des religions il s'applique
aussi à l'islamisme c'est à dire non pas
à la religion musulmane mais un projet
politique qui dévoila religion musulmane
pour imposer une autre forme
d'organisation politique dans notre pays
et le pays la france qui a inventé la
laïcité qui est même la seule à
aujourd'hui la défendre et la pratique
et a besoin de se défendre contre ça
mais c'est pas la peine de se cacher
derrière son petit doigt
il ya effectivement un projet politique
qui dévoient une religion cette religion
elle est la première victime
ces croyants sont les premières victimes
de ce projet politique et donc vous
l'attaquez notamment à travers la partie
financière qui est une partie un enjeu
lourd on vous proposera d'ailleurs de
compléter un certain nombre de mesures
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur par
exemple en faisant en sorte que dans les
associations de 1907 loi 1907
on est des compte bancaire séparé parce
qu'il est trop facile de collecter de
l'argent pour la parole pour la religion
et ensuite d'avoir des oeuvres
caritatives qui en réalité ont une autre
visée que la seule charité je doit
regretter à montaut monsieur le
président l'interprétation très excessif
de l'article 45 qui a été fait sur les
amendes dont je vais vous en prendre un
exemple
l'amendement 1186 que nous avions déposé
qui vise à faire en sorte que quand se
produisent des événement aussi
dramatique que ce qu'on a connu à dijon
ou à décines ou des groupes ethniques
s'en prennent à d'autres groupes
ethniques on puisse désormais les
sanctionner en tant que tel plus
gravement que si c'était les individus
séparément il a été semble-t-il écarté
au titre de l'article 45
je pense pour autant que c'est un délit
qui devrait exister je ne vois pas en
quoi les autres articles qui viennent
renforcer ou créer des infractions au
code pénal serait différent de celui ci
partageant la même philosophie
enfin je veux en venir à au sujet qui
porte sur l'enseignement c'est une de
nos principales préoccupations sur le
fait qu'on manque la cible
aujourd'hui se développe évidemment une
volonté chez certains des cartes et
leurs enfants de l'école de la
république soit parfois au sein de
l'enseignement public en refusant tel ou
tel type d'enseignement soit à travers
les écoles hors contrat soit beaucoup
plus occasionnellement manifestement à
travers l'instruction aux familles
l'instruction en famille elle est
marginale dans cette affaire et nous
pensons que vous auriez dû beaucoup plus
le sioniste de l'éducation
vous intéressez aux écoles hors contrat
comme nous l'avons fait avec votre
coopération concernant la loi gatel qui
a été adopté mais ce n'est pas suffisant
aujourd'hui elle concerne plus de monde
bien plus sans radar et je veux ici
souligner à la fois le risque
d'inconstitutionnalité du régime
d'autorisation que vous entendez créé
pour l'instruction en famille alors que
nous préférons un régime de déclaration
et de contrôle de contrôle réel de
contrôle effectif le parlementaire de
seine-saint-denis que je suis est très
attaché au contrôle effectif j'ai vu
progresser un certain nombre de demandes
plus que les contrôles n'ont su
progresser le régime déclaratif avec
avec contrôle effectif nous paraît très
bien préférable et je répète il serait
quand même assez paradoxal que
l'éducation les écoles hors contrat soit
sur régime déclaratif alors qu'elles
n'ont quasiment pas de contrôle et que
l'instruction en famille se retrouve
sous un régime d'autorisation préalable
dont on peut craindre qu'il soit est
interprétée excessivement sait
d'ailleurs si vrai que dans le texte
le nombre d'autorisations potentiel
prévu semble très limitatif par exemple
reconnaître un citoyen français la
possibilité d'avoir un projet éducatif
personnel pour son enfant sans aucun
rapport avec aucune forme de religion
d'intégristes d'exclusive et simplement
d'amener son enfant à s'accomplir à
s'épanouir différemment c'est autorisé
dans les écoles hors contrat n'y a pas
de raison que ça ne le soit pas dans les
familles merci monsieur le député
monsieur le président la garde la parole
est maintenant monsieur charles de
courson pour le groupe liberté et
territoires monsieur le président madame
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
ce projet de loi pose une question
fondamentale les articles qui le comme
aux permettront-ils de conforter les
principes républicains et surtout
permettront-ils de lutter contre les
séparatistes
conformément à l'appellation initial de
ce texte et à son exposé des motifs
ce texte se veut ambitieux gouvernement
et la majorité venant faire un marqueur
politique en témoigne le grand nombre de
ministres auditionnés en commission est
présent aujourd'hui face à des
thématiques hystérise le débat nous
formulons un voeu que nous parvenions à
dépassionner les
ce texte touche à de très nombreux
sujets en matière de services publics
d'ordre public d'enseignement
d'associations d'exercice du culte
il modifie plusieurs de nos lois
emblématiques la loi sur la liberté de
la presse de 1881 la loi de séparation
des églises et de l'état de 1905
enfin et touche à beaucoup de nos
libertés fondamentales la liberté
d'enseigner la liberté d'association la
liberté de culte la liberté de
communication notamment en guise de
propos limitèrent je veux rappeler que
nous pensons tous comme le gouvernement
que l'islam radical
ou plutôt le fondamentalisme islamique
constitue une menace importante pour
notre société à ce titre nous partageons
la volonté affichée de s'attaquer à ce
problème et de réaffirmer notre
attachement collectif au principe
fondamental de la laïcité c'est avec cet
état d'esprit que nous avons entamé
l'examen de ce texte
cependant la lecture détaillée des
articles et les auditions nous amène à
réviser ce jugement
en un mot votre texte en l'état vous
semble raté sa cible
censé viser l'islam radical ou plutôt le
fondamentalisme islamique
il va surtout rendre la vie plus
compliquée un nombre considérable de
parents d'associations de croyants de
diverses religions qui sont tous de bons
républicains qu'ils respectent les
règles de la république et qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le fanatisme visé pour
notre part nous estimons que les
artistes de c'était peuvent être
répartis en trois catégories les
articles qui apporte une réelle
amélioration à l'état du droit des
articles qui pourrait être acceptable
sous réserve d'un montant significatif
et enfin les articles qui sont dangereux
car soit attentatoires aux libertés
fondamentales soient inutiles il y en a
quelques-uns car déjà couverts par le
droit existant soit c'est le cas de
certains est inapplicable
commençons par ce que nous approuvons
nous approuvons les mesures prises pour
protéger les fonctionnaires les selles
pour rendre plus effectif le principe de
neutralité du service public
nous regrettons néanmoins que le
périmètre d'application de ces mesures
ne soient pas défini de façon
suffisamment précise dans la loi peut
décemment nom et pour voir
il en est de même pour le concept de
contrat d'engagement républicain mais la
république n'est pas un contrat il faut
parler d'engagement à respecter les
principes républicains
ensuite sur d'autres articles nous en
partageons l'ambition mais ils
paraissent parfois inutiles car déjà
couverts par le droit existant on peut
applicables nous sommes dans
l'incantatoire l'affichage contribuant
une prolifération législatif qui
affaiblit in fine et la loi nous donne
quelques exemples le cas du chapitre
portant sur la dignité humaine comment
faire appliquer les mécanismes de
pension réservataires tous les notaires
nous disent que c'est totalement
inapplicable ou les pensions de
réversion pour les épouses de polygame
étrangers alors que le texte prévoit que
ces mesures devront se fait en
respectant les engagements
internationaux de la france qui prévoit
le partage c'est à dire exactement l
inverse et que le gouvernement y en a
quatorze veut pas dénoncer cela est tout
simplement impossible
on va conduire à créer des contentions
internationaux sans fin il en est de
même sur les sanctions à l'égard de
médecins ayant délivré de ses pseudos
certificat de virginité pour protéger
des jeunes femmes ce sont les personnes
qui force les jeunes femmes a demandé
des cervicales virginité comme l'a
rappelé notre rapporteur qui doit être
sanctionné enfin des articles ou sans
quant à eux attentatoire aux libertés
fondamentales
cela concerne la plupart des mesures
relatives aux associations notamment
l'article 6 3 latifa l'exercice du culte
l'article 21 relative à l'enseignement
en famille et l'article 18 relative à la
lutte contre l'aèdes en ligne nous avons
eu des échanges sur ces dispositions
sont notre groupe et notamment sur ces
trois articles 6 18 et 21 notamment nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir largement
nombre d' art est consacré à l'exercice
des cultes vont également créer des
lourdeurs administratives comptables
importantes et coûteuses pour l'ensemble
des associations cultuelles et ainsi
dégradé d'attractivité de la loi de 1905
malgré la possibilité de détenir des
immeubles de rapport soit l'exact soir
l'exact inverse de l'objectif affiché
par la présente nous pourrions ajouter à
une quatrième catégorie de textes qui
regrouperait ce que votre texte de
compte
pas nous savions nous aurions attendu
conformément au discours du 20 octobre
2020 des mureaux du président de la
république d'un texte ambitionnons de
conforter le principe républicain des
mesures visant par exemple à favoriser
l'éducation la laïcité souvent mal
comprise l'intégration matière d'emploi
où la mixité sociale dans le logement
hors de tout cela il n'est pas question
votre texte se veut répressif elles
l'auraient dû être équilibré par un
volet éducatif économique et social dans
un tout autre registre la question des
prisons qui est un sujet crucial pour
lutter contre l'islam radical
ou plutôt le fondamentalisme islamique
n'est pas traitée quant à la question
des moyens n'est jamais évoquée alors
que c'est bien souvent ce qui manque
avant tout plutôt qu'un nouvel arsenal
joly
en conclusion à la différence de la loi
de 1905 qui était une voix libérales d'
équilibre fait de compromis
il en va autrement de votre texte qui
est en l'état déséquilibré et qui
tombent souvent pour des dispositions
liberticides merci monsieur le député la
parole est maintenant à monsieur alexis
corbière pour le groupe la france
insoumise merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues oui des attaques ont eu
lieu contre la république
oui la république aujourd'hui est
affaiblie elle est affaiblie sur
plusieurs sujets dans un pays où il a
pris aujourd'hui 9 millions de gens qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté la
république est effectivement aujourd'hui
remis en cause dans un pays où les
violences sociales sont là elle est
effectivement en danger s'intéresser et
débattre adopte un texte de loi sur le
respect des républicains le respect des
principes républicains est une grande
tâche
il implique pour cela aussi de pouvoir
discuter et non pas agité mais agir
agité des thèmes
c'est parfois une facilité médiatique et
si l'on veut agir il faut avoir des
constats partagés
je dois vous est d'ores et déjà que au
cours de ces nombreuses auditions la
demande de chiffres de fait d'éléments
factuels en singulièrement manqué bien
souvent si effectivement il s'agit de
considérer qu'il ya une volonté forte
dans notre pays que plus jamais aucun
attentat en l'occurrence les derniers
attentats
cet érudit islamique ne vont frapper
cette exigence existe
mais s'il s'agit d'un texte comme cela a
été dit qui veut agir sur le terreau du
terrorisme il faut aller plus loin et
comprendre comprendre indiscutablement
comment nous en sommes arrivés là et je
dois rue qu'au cours de ces nombreuses
auditions
nous avons gelé dit manquer de chiffres
de constat quelles sont les dynamiques
de choses que nous sommes en train sur
lesquels nous voulons légiférer
sont-elles résiduelles sont elles en
régression sont elles à d'augmentation
est la seule augmentation des crimes qui
ont eu lieu ne suffit pas par exemple
lorsque nous décidons dans ce texte de
demander à l'ensemble des associations
de respecter un contrat dit républicain
et qu'ensuite la ministre jacqueline
gourault nous dit que je la cite on sait
que dans la plupart des cas il n'y a
rien à redire sur les associations qui
reçoivent les subventions seront aussi
ce texte n'est pas disproportionnée par
rapport à l'objectif que apte il veut
attendre quand la défenseure des droits
des droits nous dit au cours des
auditions qu'il a dans ce texte des
risques d'atteinte aux libertés je la
cite sur nombre de libertés
fondamentales il ya de quoi s'interroger
quand nous recevons les représentants du
medef que vous écoutez généralement et
qui disent que nous n'avons rien demandé
ras sur la radicalité d'entreprise
l'arsenal législatif nous paraît
suffisant il faut des peut-être les
entende les organisations syndicales des
salariés dans leur ensemble nous ont dit
que pour leur part la loi suffisait il
n'y avait pas de soutien de leur part
sur ce texte
les associations philosophie que nous
avons entendu dans leur ensemble
effectivement ne se sont pas totalement
reconnue dans le détail des articles que
vous présentez ces noms là quelque chose
qui est important parce que certes nous
avons beaucoup travaillé monsieur le
ministre d'alan à le souligner mais nous
avons travaillé d'arrache-pied
on fait référence à la loi de 1905 mais
ça a été évoqué il a occasionné deux ans
de travaux nous c'est en deux mois
attention donc vouloir comprendre ça
n'est pas excusé vouloir comprendre
c'est être efficace
alors où en sommes-nous dans ce cadre là
premièrement et je voudrais terminer ce
propos en disant que puisqu'il s'agit
c'est dans l'avant-propos de s'en
prendre notamment ce séparatisme
d'origine islamiste
non monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
pardon je vous cite à nouveau je ne suis
pas d'accord pour que ces travaux
commencent en disant qu'il ya une au pea
politique de l'islamisme politique nos
pea sur l'islam de france non non la
représentante du renseignement nous a
bien indiqué que dans 96% des lieux de
culte
le musulman il n'y a aucun problème
cette formule me semble assez ramassé
est inutile alors nos propositions qui
ont été pour l'instant censure et je le
regrette je reviens pas sur
l'utilisation abusive de l'article 45
oui si l'on veut défendre la loi de 1905
elle doit s'appliquer sur l'ensemble du
territoire ce texte doit abroger le
concordat d'alsace-moselle qui marque un
privilège pour près de 3 millions de
concitoyens et qui coûtent chaque année
60 millions d'euros
défendre la 1905 c'est la défendre dans
son ensemble et rien ne justifie qu'il y
ait cette singularité
oui nous demandons la suppression des
avantages fiscaux aujourd'hui qui
finance le culte car c'est cela la
laïcité l'article 2 de la loi de 1905
les services fiscaux sont incapables d
d'établir totalement ce qu'il représente
mais c'est sans doute plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros
oui la loi de 1905 qui dit que la
république ne reconnaît aucun culte doit
nous imposer de nous interdire toute
volonté de nous immiscer dans
l'organisation de certains cultes ils
doivent respecter la loi sans aucun
doute mais ce n'est pas à nous de dire
comment ils doivent s'organiser me
semble-t-il
oui les associations ne doivent pas
subir une suspicion généralisée je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure rien ne le justifie
ceux qui contreviennent à la loi doivent
être sanctionnés mais d'aucune manière
nous avons à considérer que l or est par
définition un comportement qui devrait
amener à ce que tout à 100 % doivent de
se soumettre à une déclaration que nous
ne nous reconnaissons pas d'ailleurs que
comme législateur qui serait ce contrat
d'engagement républicain enfin l'école
l'école publique est le coeur de tous il
s'agit de réinvestir l'école publique
mais elle est en danger elle est déjà
mise en concurrence avec une école
privée privés sous contrat privés hors
contrat que nous finançons je reviendrai
pas sur la 1959 la loi debré qui coûte
quand même contribuable dix milliards
d'euros mais aussi aujourd'hui tous les
avantages doit quand même la loi
bancaire dernièrement qui amènent des
surcoûts de la part des communes pour
financer l'école privée nous avons aussi
là dessus a renforcé les contrôles
nous avons aussi à garantir l'ensemble
nos fonctionnaires l'assurance de la
protection fonctionnelle qui n'est pas
mise en application lorsque nos
fonctionnaires sont en danger
je termine sur une chose dans la grande
promesse qu'avait été fait dans
l'histoire du présent la république aux
mureaux il ya aussi le constat qu' il ya
aujourd'hui des quartiers relégué par
nombre de menaces et qu'il faut agir
c'est totalement absente de ce texte
et c'est un problème et de premier
ministre en 2015 avait considéré qu'il y
avait un apartheid territoriale sociale
ethnique
emmanuel macron a dénoncé
ghettoïsation de la réplique à la
république a laissé faire et tout cela
est complètement absente ce texte est
tous les amendements que nous avions
présentées à ce sujet pour casser
véritablement cette ségrégation sociale
et pour aussi remettre en cause le
séparatisme des riches qu'ils en étant
la conséquence de l'autre et vice versa
ne pourront pas être discutée voilà
pourquoi nous pensons que ce texte rate
sa cible qu'il est un texte de suspicion
généralisée qui déteint texte qui remet
en cause la banque comprend sans loi
1905 et qui ne donnent pas véritablement
les moyens de lutter contre le
terrorisme
c'est quoi lutter contre le rhume s'est
donné les moyens à nos services de
renseignement s'est renforcée pharos
essais remporte aussi la miviludes la
mission de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires si l'on méritait d'être
efficace face à des comportements que
nous pouvons faire c'est mon cher
collègue
la parole est maintenant madame marie
george buffet pour le groupe de la
gauche démocrate et républicaine
c'est la dernière oratrice de groupe
merci monsieur le président ce texte sur
le respect des passifs de la république
aurait besoin pour être opérant peut
soit traité dans le même temps du
renforcement de la place de l'état d'un
service public réarmer sur l'ensemble du
territoire de la mixité sociale et de la
lutte contre les inégalités qui sapent
notre cohésion sociale sans politique
sociale ambitieuse sans avancée de la
démocratie ne pourrons lutter pleinement
contre l'atomisation de la société et la
nomine sociale cependant ce projet de
loi est nécessaire et nous devons nous
en emparer pleinement pour construire
ensemble des dispositifs efficaces pour
lutter contre les graves dérives qui
frappent douloureusement notre pays tout
en étant respectueux des droits et des
libertés des individus
je suis sûr que nos débats se passeront
dans un esprit serein sans ce film sans
stigmatisation de nos compatriotes de
confession musulmane qui demandent qu'à
vivre sereinement au sein de notre
république dans le respect de ces
principes
oui il y a nécessité d'agir contre les
extrémismes religieux contre les
prêcheurs de haine les manipulateurs en
tout genre que ce soit à travers l'islam
radical ou toute autre pratique allant à
l'encontre de nos principes et de
nouveau il n'y a pas lieu de toucher à
la loi de 1905 qui reste une profonde
modernité et qui par son équilibre
garantit cette articulation si délicate
autre principe de même valeur nous ne
souhaitons pas de lois concordataires
l'objectif que nous devons nous fixer et
de travailler et l'efficacité de cette
loi compte tenu de ses objectifs c'est à
dire lutter contre tous les séparatismes
nous soutiendrons certains dispositifs
notamment seront ce relative à la
neutralité du service public à la
dignité humaine et à l'école concernant
la dignité humaine la lutte contre la
polygamie les mariages forcés ou du
certificat de virginité est un impératif
et la loi de tes petits prés semant les
interdits j'alerte cependant sur le fait
que de telles que rédigé certains
articles pourraient avoir des
conséquences indirectes en particulier
sur le statut des femmes étrangères
je me félicite donc de l'amendement
présenté par madame la rapporteure du
bre chirat de même les dispositions
concernant l'école en particulier
l'obligation scolaire vont dans le bon
sens je suis de ma famille politique
extrêmement attachés à l'école
républicaine et je crois profondément
que l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
commandes pilat et à l'école à l'école
de la république la rédaction actuelle
de l'article instaurant un régime
d'autorisation préalable nous apparaît
équilibré nous allons par voie
d'amendement nous assurer tout
l'harmonisation sur le territoire des
critères d'acceptation de la dérogation
et la collégialité de la décision
concernant les écoles hors contrat nous
sommes également favorables à un
renforcement stricte de leur contrôle
car de nombreuses dérives ont été
constatées et nous poserons aussi la
question de la pertinence de conserver
en france de telles structures
je suis plus réservé sur les dispositifs
concernant les associations et des
fédérations sportives en particulier sur
le contrat d'engagement républicain tout
d'abord je vois un paradoxe à augmenter
les contrôles sur le monde associatif
je tends une sorte de suspicion
généralisée accord le alors que l'état
se repose de plus en plus sur les
associations pour mener des politiques
publiques
là où les services publics ont été
désengagé les associations assurent un
lien social indispensable et participe
grandement à la cohésion du pays
si les associations se voir imposer de
nouvelles obligations
il faut aussi que l'état soit la hauteur
de leurs engagements et prenne ses
responsabilités pour lutter contre la
fragmentation de notre société
un contrats se signent à plusieurs force
est de constater qu ici seules les
associations et les fédérations prennent
des engagements des engagements que la
plupart portent déjà au quotidien
dire cela n'est pas méconnaître les
difficultés que posent certaines
associations aux influences néfastes de
plus contractualisé des principes
fondamentaux interroge quels moyens de
contrôle pour les associations et les
fédérations
la laïcité ne fait pas partie dans le
texte actuel des principes républicains
présents dans le contrat c'est
incompréhensible
enfin nous ne connaissons pas la
rédaction de son contrat ni même s'il y
aura différents contrats selon le type
d'association nous législateurs et
légiste l'actrice nous ne pouvons
avancer à la vol ce n'est pas normal il
nous ne voterons ce ne voteront pas tant
que nous ne connaissons pas son ses
contenus enfin nous sommes réservés pour
des raisons que nous développons lors
des débats sur les articles 18 et 20 où
elle a brièvement le positionnement du
groupe gdr nous espérons être entendus
sur nos amendements et c'est avec comme
fil conducteur tout la loi de 1905 que
nous développerons nunnally je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame la députée merci
mes chers collègues pour ses
interventions
nous allons maintenant avoir quelques
réponses de monsieur et madame la
ministre
et si vous le voulez bien nous allons
commencer par monsieur jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale m'a fait savoir qu'il devait
ensuite quitter la réunion
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci me donner ainsi la parole
pardonnez moi de vous quitter tout à
l'heure je peux être très bref dans les
réponses sur certains points nos
interventions liminaire apporter
certaines certaines réponses
je voudrais commencer par une remarque
générale que je
que je retire de ce qu'a dit le
président lagarde tout à l'heure
lorsqu'il a dit que la laïcité était on
ne la trouvait qu'en france je devrais
la fois factuellement et
philosophiquement et apporter une
contradiction à cette affirmation
factuellement parce qu'il ya d'autres
pays qui fort heureusement consacre la
laïcité
jusqu'à il ya peu de temps la turquie ce
qui montre bien que c'est adaptable sous
tous les cieux et je pense que c'est
extrêmement important de l'alliance
approuve que c'est faisable c'est que
c'est faisable partout mais on pourrait
citer d'autres pays comme l'uruguay en
amérique latine et d'ailleurs d'autres
d'autres pays encore si je dis ça c'est
pas simplement pour le plaisir d'un
débat historique et géopolitique
c'est pour dire que nous devons avoir
une vision offensive fier de la laïcité
la laïcité n'est pas un concept désuet à
la française il ya beaucoup de force à
l'échelle internationale et parfois
nationale pour essayer de nous faire
croire que ce serait quelque chose de
désuet et de perdus c'est tout le
contraire la laïcité est un principe qui
est une clé pour le 21e siècle et
notamment une clé pour beaucoup de
sociétés peut-être même toutes les
sociétés
elle peut s'appeler autrement dans
d'autres pays d'ailleurs pas là c'est
pas cela question sémantique qui compte
en l'occurrence qui compte c'est ce
qu'on met derrière ça c'est à dire tout
simplement l'égalité des êtres humains
sur cette planète et dans chaque société
c'est un point majeur de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme de 1789 et parfois
certains veulent nous le faire perdre en
route et faire comme si c'était un petit
sujet à la française jeunesse a entre
guillemets c'est un sujet extrêmement
important sur lequel il ya actuellement
de grands combats philosophique et
politique et ne le perdons pas de vue
lorsque nous débattons de cela beaucoup
pour ma part en tout cas et c'est là
c'est la proche gouvernement et on le
voit dans le discours du président des
mureaux cette approche héritière de la
philosophie des lumières nous là nous en
nous en sommes fiers et nous ne
considérons pas que c'est un point
spécifiquement français il ya aussi un
sujet à l'échelle de l'europe
on l'a vu au moment de l'assassinât du
professeur samuel pâtit
j'ai pour ma part travailler à ce que
plusieurs pays européens manifestent
très clairement leur solidarité des
minutes de silence ont été consacrés
aimé débat avec mes homologues européens
me montrent que le principe de laïcité
loin d'être une particularité française
un peu bizarre est au contraire quelque
chose qui intéresse parce que tout le
monde est confronté au même sujet du
commun du communautarisme
nous ne sommes pas adeptes du système à
l'américaine ce que nous sommes adeptes
du système républicain dont nous avons
la chance d'être les héritiers
ce point est majeur parce que à mon avis
les transversales à tout ce que nous
avons à dire sur le sujet que ce soit
sur l'école ou sur ou sur d'autres
points ensuite plusieurs catégories de
choses ont été dites
la rapporteure en brune ira et est allé
un peu dans le détail sur les
évolution qui lui semble souhaitable
qu'ils soient eux-mêmes le fruit de
toutes les réflexions collectives qui
ont eu lieu
je vais moi même parvenir dans le détail
de ce qu'elle a dit mais je voudrais
redire ce que j'ai dit en introduction
sur le sujet c'est à dire nous sommes
évidemment ouverts la plupart des
évolutions qui ont été proposées par
différents députés lors des discussions
précédentes tout simplement parce que
justement nous avons une approche
équilibrée
quelques-uns d'entre vous va comme sur
le député de courson on dit que elle
ressemblait pas la loi de 1905 qui elle
était équilibré je crois que monsieur
corbières l'a dit aussi justement je
pense que nous arrivons un travail dont
on verra s'il peut se comparer c'est à
dire un travail qui est le fruit d'un
véritable dialogue et d'une approche
justement très équilibré nous devons
simplement dans équilibré bien entendre
ce que cela signifie c'est à dire ne pas
perdre l'élan initial
il ne faudrait pas que par petites
touches à force de vouloir modifier ce
que le président a dit aux mureaux où ce
que l'élan initial qu'il traduisait
était on finisse par à fort d'être
équilibré de vouloir écrire et être
déséquilibré c'est pourquoi nous sommes
ouverts à 2 à des amendements nous avons
été déjà ouverts à des modifications
mais sans perdre l'élan initial et sur
les sujets qui sont les miens je
voudrais rappeler ce que c'est en
répondant à plusieurs observations qui
ont été faites d'abord équilibré ça veut
dire être équilibré sur le plan social
par rapport au plan régalien est là
aussi
soyons très clairs cette loi ne prétend
pas être l'alpha et l'oméga de ce qu'il
y à dire sur l'ensemble des sujets
sociaux et sociétaux donc bien sûr que
nous devons avancer sur des gens mais je
pense que tout le monde en est d'accord
le volet social n'est pas forcément
inscrits dans cette loi et n'est pas
forcément de domaine législatif
si l'on prend le dédoublement des
classes de cp et de ce1 en
on éducation prioritaire il va et
évident que c'est une mesure sociale
c'est une mesure qui conforte la
république correspond à l'esprit de ce
que plusieurs d'entre vous viennent de
réclamer comme un instant madame la
députée marie-george buffet 7 mais
évidemment ça n'a pas attendu cette loi
est et on ne peut pas attendre de cette
loi qu'elle résolve tous les problèmes
de la société française donc je pense
que ce sera un argument un petit peu un
petit peu facile finalement que de
s'opposer à cette loi au nom du fait
qu'elle ne résout pas tous nos problèmes
sociaux nous avons à travailler sur les
sujets sociaux c'est évident c'est la
deuxième jambe
nous l'avons fait ne pas rentrer dans
toutes les mesures qu'il illustre nous
continuerons à le faire de façon
législatives parfois de façon infra
législatives et est donc
philosophiquement il n'y a aucun doute
sur le fait que nous voulons avancer sur
deux jambes il se trouve que la jambe
que nous vous présentons est plutôt
régaliennes et que c'est assumé assumée
comme telle et s'agissant de l'autre
observation qui nous est fait à
plusieurs reprises qui est de manquer la
cible
c'est une expression que plusieurs
d'entre vous avaient avaient utilisé je
ne crois pas mais c'est à vous nous
aider de ne pas la manquer puisque ça
renvoie ce que je disais tout à l'heure
sur l' équilibre du texte trop le troll
le critiquer trop
à trop vouloir l'édulcorer parfois on
pourrait en effet risquer de manquer de
manquer la cible et l'idée de 6,2 manqué
la cible signifie qu'il y aurait des
balles perdues signifie qu'il y aurait
comme je les ai entendus à plusieurs
reprises des libertés qui serait
atteinte pour des personnes qui ne sont
pas normalement visé par par la houle
s'est évidemment pas le but je ne crois
pas que ce soit ce soit le cas je pense
que les exigences que nous avons en
matière scolaire sont parfaitement
proportionné et qu'elles peuvent tout
simplement accomplir les principes
républicains c'est à dire qu'il est
normal de considérer que on que la
question de l'éducation n'est pas une
question ordinaire pour laquelle il y
aurait une sorte d'anarchie dans
l'exercice de la liberté
de ce point de vue là je voudrais
remercier madame la députée buffet pour
ce qu'elle a dit est finalement la
fidélité aux principes qui sont les
siens dans ce qu'elle a dit qu'on
devrait retrouver à peu près dans son
spectre politique il me semble que la
question de l'école républicaine depuis
les débuts est une question de droits de
l'enfant que si on considère que l'on
fait ce que l'on veut en la matière
parce que certains seraient en quelque
sorte propriétaire des enfants on viole
les principes républicains que ça vaut
pour l'islamisme radical mais ça peut
valoir pour d'autres sujets comme les
sectes par exemple et à juste titre il a
été fait référence à cela par monsieur
corbières tout à l'heure donc il y aura
un progrès certain en la matière par le
régime de l'autorisation vers lequel
nous allons
et lorsque monsieur
la garde monsieur le président la gare
nous dit que ont raté la cible parce
qu'on ne parlerait que du hors contrat
que pardon que de l'instruction en
famille là où il faudrait parler
davantage du hors contrat je dirais
qu'on a arrêté quatre sujets et que les
quatre sujets sont abordés par le
travail législatif de ce quinquennat
le premier c'est être capable
d'identifier les enfants sur un
territoire donné et vous le savez c'est
une chose sur lesquels nous souhaitons
progresser il n'est pas normal que des
enfants soient au radar on retrouve
d'ailleurs de nouveau le sujet social si
on repère les enfants c'est à la fois
pour des politiques sociales et des
politiques éducatives et c'est donc dans
l'intérêt des enfants que ce travail
doit être fait et donc il est ce sujet
avance deuxièmement il y a et vous avez
raison monsieur le président la garde
le sujet du hors contrat mais comme vous
l'avez souligné vous même
nous n'avons pas rien fait en la matière
il ya les sujets la régulation des
ouvertures et il ya le sujet de la
fermeture sur la régulation des
ouvertures la loi gatel a eu
d'excellents de conséquences dont je
suis évidemment l'agent quant à
l'exécution puisque depuis la loi
guethem nous sommes beaucoup plus
efficaces pour empêcher l'ouverture
d'écoles hors contrat dans le projet ne
correspondrait pas aux valeurs de la
république et c'est ainsi que nous avons
pu empêcher d ouverture depuis de
rentrée scolaire ce qui n'était pas le
cas auparavant
c'est donc un progrès et ce progrès déjà
accomplis s'agissant et donc sur ce
deuxième sujet les choses si je puis
dire son fait
j'étais moi même le premier a considéré
que par contre la loi gatel étaient
insuffisantes pour les fermetures et
c'est pourquoi cette loi portent une
disposition sur la fermeture des écoles
hors contrat c'est un point qui est
peut-être trop occulté dans les débats
parce que tous portent sur les débats
portent sur l'instruction en famille
mais on ne doit pas méconnaître le fait
que la loi à disposition très importante
sur la fermeture des administratifs des
écoles hors contrat donc sur les écoles
hors contrat nous nous apprêtons à voir
la deuxième lame du rasoir si je puis
dire ce qui va permettre de distinguer
du hors contrat normal qui a tout à fait
le droit de cité en france dans une
dans un pays de liberté et de leurs
contrats problématiques qui ne doit pas
exister
donc on pouvait dire qu'en 2017 qu'il
était plus facile d'ouvrir une école qu
un bar en france selon de nos lois en
2022 ce ne sera plus vrai et ça l'est
déjà beaucoup moins vrai depuis la loi
gatel ça sera plus du tout avec cette
fois et puis en quatrième lieu il y à
l'instruction en famille et je serais
d'accord avec vous si nous ne parlons
que de cela nous ne devrions la cible
mais ce qui est dit dans ce projet de
loi vient compléter les trois autres
points que je disais donc tout n'est pas
dans cette loi soit parce que des choses
y sont ont déjà été consacrés soit parce
que cela parfois relève de l'infra
législatives voilà monsieur le président
je ne veux pas être plus long mais je
souhaitais apporter déjà c'est ces
précisions
je pense que ce que je peux dire sur la
partie éducation jeunesse et sports sera
serait
vrai aussi pour les autres domaines
comme le diront certainement mais mes
collègues ensuite c'est à dire qu'on est
justement sûr que sur un projet de loi
équilibré et qui est aussi
complémentaires d'autres dispositions
c'est aussi un projet de loi qui
recherche l'efficacité
cette efficacité qui doit correspondre
au diagnostic qui est fait que la
plupart d'entre vous avaient fait par
vos propos liminaires et donc sur ce
point je crois que nous sommes d'accord
sur le diagnostic et ne reste plus qu'à
voir les mesures adaptées à ce
diagnostic je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale la parole est
maintenant monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur ainsi monsieur le président
avant de répondre être très brièvement
qu'on vous a tapé la sueur au cap les
deux fait puisque des amendements
donneront l'occasion d'échanger sur
chacun des sujets je vous réfère trois
remarques très rapide en entendant
chacune et chacun d'entre vous d'abord
constater qu'à une ou deux exceptions
près et encore ils ne l'ont pas
formalisé tous les groupes représentés à
l'assemblée nationale évoque le fait que
c'est un texte qui pose des questions
légitimes dans un contexte qui
effectivement été un contexte où il
devait avoir une réponse politique forte
de l'état et dont je n'ai pas entendu
j'ai compris fait de la part de la
france a soumis ce même si monsieur
députés ne l'a pas formalisé de gens qui
se disaient que des débuts de votre est
contre c'est un texte intéressant de ce
point de vue puisque dès le début des
discussions alors qu'on nous annonçait
une grande fracture
je constate effectivement que sur les
attendus et ce même le principe satan
ont dit on va voir ce que donnera lé
débat parlementaire
il n'y a pas d'opposition de principe à
un texte je crois que c'est assez rare
pour être souligné surtout lorsqu'il est
aussi médiatique et jean verser chacune
et chacun d'entre vous si cela était
possible ça montre à la fois le travail
en amont qu'a pu faire le gouvernement
mais aussi le travail de la commission
spéciale et je voudrais dire que le
gouvernement vient avec vers une
question compliquée des idées simples et
voudra bien volontiers adopté des
amendements d'où qu'ils viennent et avec
l'intérêt général au corps deuxièmement
certains ont reproché qu'il n'y avait
pas l'immigration mal logement
social pas de mesures qui relèvent de la
mixité pas de mesures qui relèvent de la
politique de la ville pas de mesures qui
relèvent surtout ton pour en discuter
lors et les amendements sur ce point les
conventions internationales de la
politique internationale de la france
fin bref on pourrait faire la liste je
le contraire la vente et ce n'est pas
une déclaration de politique générale ni
votre serviteur d'idées des autres
ministres et que ce texte parle du sujet
sur lesquels effectivement il a attitré
du président de la république le
discours des mureaux c'était une
cohésion d'ensemble
le projet de loi portant est une partie
importante mais une partie seulement du
discours des mureaux cesco des mureaux
il sera complété et il ya à la fois des
questions qui relèvent à coup sûr du
lien que peut entretenir le séparatisme
les séparatismes avec la difficulté
effectivement avoir entassé il n'y a pas
d'autre mot et en tant que maire d'une
commune qui connaît ses difficultés
j'ai pu appréhender lorsque j'étais élu
je peux constater que la politique de
peuplement la non mixité sociale
les difficultés économiques l'urbanisme
contribue évidemment au séparatisme est
également on peut y voir aussi un lien
avec les difficultés internationale et
des questions qui relèvent de
l'immigration cependant nous ne mettons
pas un signe égal
nous ne disons pas immigration égale
séparatisme ils sont jeunes ils ont pas
de mixité sociale égale séparatisme les
choses ont un peu plus complexe que
celle ci il y aura d'autres dispositions
qui permettront d'en parler mais a
cautionné ne s'agit pas d'un texte
résumant l'action générale petit
gouvernementale de l'alpha et l'oméga le
beau proverbe africain dit qu'il faut
tout un village pour élever un enfant il
faut sans doute toute une politique
publique pour mettre fin à ces questions
si importante et si longtemps éloigné du
regard public et des mesures
législatives
troisièmement certains critiquent le
fait que c'était très urgent et qu'il
fallait le prendre et intelligence
certains disent mais pourquoi tant de
précipitation donc sans doute est-ce que
le mieux est sans doute le mieux 1 et
que s'il n'y a ni urgence absolue ni
lenteur excessive est commise et victor
hugo nous nous hâtons lentement mais
sûrement
sachant qu effectivement nous touchons
d'une main tremblante des libertés
fondamentales particulièrement regardé
c'est bien normal pour nos concitoyens
parce que des armes à la bonne heure de
bonheur de la démocratie c'est de
combattre ceux qui l'attaquent avec les
armes de la démocratie c'est ce qui est
plus difficile évidemment
alors je constate cependant que beaucoup
de gens ont dit des impôts quelques
personnes par donc on dit le texte
atteint des libertés fondamentales jeu
j'étais parlementaire un mandat ici
j'avais 3 ans et demi bientôt que je
suis mise e république
je n'ai jamais vu un avis du conseil
d'état à ce point soulignant alors que
les sujets sont monsieur garde des
sceaux très important et touche
évidemment des mains tremblantes
assemble des grandes dispositions de
grandes jurisprudence le travail du
gouvernement qui a corrigé sa copie à
quasiment toutes les exceptions près
selon le conseil d'état sont à des
finalités
c'est à remarquer n'a pas été ce
grondement sourd et muet aux remarques
du conseil d'état et je constate par
ailleurs je voudrais juste dire même la
députée représentant le groupe
socialiste que je m'inscris en faux cils
me le permet aider des personnes qui
nous suivent pour le constater d'étude
d'impact 403 page ou alors elle et on
n'a pas eu la même étude d'impact mais
elle est très complète les gens là c'est
d'ailleurs tous ceux qui ont beaucoup
travaillé à l'otan ainsi le travail qu'a
fait l'administration évidemment
parlementaire alors pour entrer dans le
vif du sujet les quelques remarques
l'inversé des rapporteurs et jeudi d'
avance que je suivrai très grande partie
de leurs propositions
c'est le cas pour ce qui concerne le
directement des textes j'aurais apporté
évidemment d'aller chez ski de monsieur
de monsieur ouvriers mais évidemment des
autres évocations
le gouvernement est prêt à modifier un
certain nombre de dispositions
d'ailleurs en bonne intelligence me
semble-t-il aussi avec la haute
assemblée avec qui nous avons des
relations d un amour du texte notamment
son président je remercie pour son
attitude extrêmement constructives même
si elle est pleine évidemment de
conviction comme on lui connaît sur les
interventions de monsieur diard
permettez-moi de d'évoquer le fait
monsieur le député que je ne partage pas
l'idée que les hôpitaux les prisons sont
sortis de ce texte les services publics
concernent tout le monde
ce texte s'adresse pas une religion mais
à tous les cultes
ce texte ce n'est pas un service public
mais tous les services publics le délit
de séparatisme et s'appliquera pour tous
les agents publics
quand un homme refusera de se soigner
par une femme il sera coupable et
évidemment du délit que nous évoquons la
neutralité s'appliquent dans tous les
champs du service public pas simplement
ce qui concernerait les collectivités
locales
il a même bien plus on en reparlera des
avances sans doute ce soir monsieur le
rapporteur
alors ensuite vous avez évoqué le sujet
de la radicalisation bon c'est un sujet
extrêmement important vous avez beaucoup
travaillé avec eux monsieur le député
brial il est vrai que ce texte ne
prévoyait pas de mesures ni contre le
terrorisme et de renseignement ni contre
la radicalisation mais nous aurons
l'occasion sans doute en séance publique
de discuter plus en amont autour du
rapporteur du rapporteur général madame
maltais l'intérieur a évoqué un certain
nombre de sujets je remercie de la
distinguer ce pour quoi elle pourrait
être d'accord et ce pour quoi ils sont
groupe elle se pose des questions
j'essaierai de la rassurer avec mémé mes
collègues et comme cela garde comme
monsieur de course ont évoqué le fait
que nous ne pensons pas du tout que la
cible est manquée on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler
d'ailleurs nous pensons d'ailleurs que
ces mesures sont très efficiente on aura
également l'occasion d'en reparler
on aura évidemment ce débat et et si
jamais effectivement la démonstration
est faite à linverse le gouvernement il
viendra avec eux évidemment l'attention
de retirer ce qu'ils le pourraient être
persuadé par le débat parlementaire de
ne pas être efficient sachant que les
questions sont si importantes monsieur
corbières jeu c'est bien la première
fois que je vous entends qu il me le
dira qu'il faut suivre le medef
1 j'ai même autres noté il faut entendre
le men s apprête à ce camp
non voilà bah écoutez moi j'assume de
parfois pour ne pas écouter le patronat
puisque la différence effectivement
c'est que nous avons des dispositions
qui ne relèvent pas du code du travail
ont fait ce choix c'est un point
important ça pourrait être regretter
nous pensons qu effectivement la cour de
cassation par ses divers arrêts de
jurisprudence comme le fait que le
règlement intérieur puisque c'est comme
ça qu'il s'agit
et d'ailleurs le conseil d'état le
souligne une entreprise peut si elle le
souhaite imposer y compris de point de
vue européen les principes de la laïcité
la neutralité
les entreprises et les syndicats nous
ont fait savoir en amont du texte n'est
pas besoin de dispositions particulières
aucune réunion patronales et aucune
organisation syndicale et donc nous les
avons écoutés sur ce point d'un pavé
dispositions du code de travail mais
c'est vrai que nous considérons pas que
le medef est forcément totalement son
mot à dire sur la question du service
public et de ses agents mais peut-être à
100 points différence avec nous et que
finalement la politique c'est parfois ça
c'est parfois des moments où on est des
jeux sont inversés nous ne partageons
pas monsieur le député mais ça vous aura
pas surpris votre volonté d'interdire le
concordat en alsace moselle et vous
auriez pu rajouter dans quelques
territoires ultramarins nous respectons
l'histoire de la de la république ce qui
ne veut pas dire que nous n'appliquons
pas dans lé régime concordataire des
dispositions qui auraient notamment de
la police du culte dans les insérant un
droit local parfait respect de
l'histoire de france tout en ayant les
mêmes finalités
il suffit de se balader en alsace
moselle pour s'apercevoir que
profondément le principe de laïcité même
s'il n'est pas régi par les mêmes règles
et vécu évidemment delà même de la même
manière alors vous arrivez à faire une
démonstration monsieur le député qui est
assez intéressante pour dire qu'on s'en
prend trop au culte et vous voulez tout
de suite après supprimer l'exonération
fiscale
donc nous considérons que cette
proposition qui certes rapport très
beaucoup d'argent sans doute
on pouvoirs publics eux cependant est un
peu disproportionné et d'ailleurs ce
serait sans doute contraire aux
principes mêmes de la république on en a
largement évoqué vous avez un avis du
conseil d'état qu'il explicite quand
nous renforçons les contrôles mais c'est
un débat qui est pour le coup fidèle à
ce que vous nous avez toujours exprimé
là où je vous trouve un peu moins
cohérent si vous leur mettez ces
convives donner plus de moyens aux
services de renseignements n'hésitez pas
alors ce que quand on a eu des
discussions avec le site j'ai pas
compris que le groupe était
particulièrement pour est prêt à donner
d'autres moyens au renseignement
français
et quand j'ai présenté trois budget à
chaque fois y compris sur le chapitre le
groupe n'a pas voté mais enfin des prêts
à tout à fait en parler là où je peux me
permettre de vous corriger pour pas
qu'on ait de difficultés sur les débats
c'est lorsque vous évoquez en citant la
cheffe du service enseignement d r
j'aimerais bien connaitre laquelle
puisqu'il y en a il y en a plusieurs
96% des lieux de culte musulman dit vous
ne pose aucun problème
bon parlons de venir ce chiffre est
absolument faux on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler
nous pensons nous que les lieux de culte
et singulièrement les lieux de culte qui
relève du culte musulman ont très
largement baissé en intensité dans la
menace à la menace directe avec le
terrorisme c'est certain mais aussi dans
le travail que fait d'islamisme mais
baissé d'intensité ne veut pas dire
totalement évanouie
nous pensons c'est vrai que l'islamisme
politique s'installe désormais dans la
société par les associations on l'a dit
avec jean michel blanquer dans l'école
de la république dans le sport sur
internet mais il est aussi
malheureusement aussi dans les lieux de
culte et je sais pas si vous partagerez
les mêmes avis que les dirigeants du
culte musulman qui ont signé cette
charte
ce matin il commentaires très clairement
le salafisme les frères musulmans elle
tablir et il y à de nombreux lieux de
culte qui se propage
si j'ose dire avec déclaré au nom
déclaré d'où l'intérêt du travail que
nous aurons ici pour savoir que cela ne
relève pas de lien direct avec le
terrorisme mais relève du terreau du
terrorisme
donc on aura sans doute une discussion
avoir très importante sur ce point
j'attire l'attention du parlement sous
l'article 44 qui permettra
profondément jeudi notamment à ce que
disais que nous ne nions pas assez loin
pour la première fois la république
validé par le conseil d'état va
permettre sous l'autorité du juge
lorsque miss d'intérieur prendra sa
décision de faire fermer des lieux de
culte alors qu'il n'y a aucun lien entre
ni les rp ni le terrorisme c'est ce que
fait mise intérieur aujourd'hui ne peut
pas faire fermer des lieux de culte
qu'on dit pourtant radicalise et dont la
documentation le montre tout le monde
est d'accord mais on ne peut pas
intervenir
je pense que sa disposition elle est
évidemment extrêmement nécessaire
voilà monsieur le président puisse se
soigner pour dire que désormais tout le
monde est d'accord en 1905
j'ai constaté aussi que quasiment tous
vos interlocuteurs sont venus pour dire
qu'ils étaient tous d'accord sur
l'équipe de 905 et n'a pas semblé qu'en
1905 pour avoir relu les débats
l'unanimité était une sorte y compris la
société dite civile j'ai constaté
d'ailleurs que 1905 est elle même une
loi qui fait suite au compromis de 1901
où l'état avait nationalisé les biens de
l'église et à peine votée cette loi qui
pourtant été très contestée puisqu'elle
n'était pas très bien voter elle a été
changée en 1906 puisque le parlement
s'est réuni à peine un an après pour
pouvoir refaire les 1907 qui vont nous
intéresser dans la station du cn et il
aura fallut même attendre que briand
devienne ministre et clemenceau mise à
l'intérieur pour finalement ne pas
appliquer des dispositions qu'ils
avaient pourtant poussé là au sénat
l'autre à l'assemblée et donc lorsque on
évoque l'unanimité autour de 1905 dont
je rappelle qu'elle a été modifiée plus
de 21 fois par la république et vous
même et la démission et parlementaire
deux fois rien dans ce quinquennat on
peut garder l'esprit le principe les
premiers articles que nous sommes
extrêmement attachés et que nul ne vient
en modifier mais évidemment notre
travail à nous c'est laisser faire le
plus unanimisme possible sans perdre la
force de l'autorité et de l'intérêt
général
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est peut-être à monsieur le
ministre de la justice garde des sceaux
je vais être je vais être très bref
parce que le ministre de l'intérieur a
été complet comme à son habitude mais
voyez je voudrais quand même exprimer
mon sentiment sur un certain nombre de
choses que j'ai pu entendre çà et là on
vit dans une période extrêmement
anxiogènes difficile
je pense que la parole publique de
t'être parcimonieuse notamment quand
elle évoque les grands principes et
remarqué à quel point ce qui vient de
l'état et pour certains immédiatement
suspect le rapport particulier de
certains de nos concitoyens avec la
verticalité tout ça gronde monte
encouragés par certains
on essaie de passer par une boîte privée
pour répertorier ce qu'on doit vacciner
c'est du fichage
oui on ose ça ça fait peur au gens
évidemment c'est complètement bidon mais
ça fait peur aux gens et ici on parle de
liberté on parle de séparatisme on parle
de valeurs de la république et merci à
la très très très grande majorité
d'entre vous de vous être exprimé comme
vous l'avez fait avec beaucoup de
l'intelligence de modération et dans un
esprit de concertation que nous avons
les uns et les autres
déjà pu retenir à cet instant précis
alors que nos débats n'ont pas commencé
je vous dis ça parce que il a fallu
évidemment je le redoutais que l'on
entende les mots liberticides sont des
postures en l'occurrence moi pardon mais
entravé la liberté d'un haineux qui
menace la petite mila je trouve pas ça
liberticide
je trouve ça normal entraver la liberté
de ceux qui menacent nos fonctionnaires
pour obtenir d'autres règles que celles
de la république
pour moi c'est pas liberticide on
proteste quelques belles liberté on les
déclinera marraine schiappa et le le
consentement éclairé c'est pas rien la
liberté des mecs qui l'on veut pardon je
pense à cette petite qui a été tendu
parce que elle avait commis l'infraction
suprême des mets un homme qui n'était
pas de sa religion ou de la religion de
sa famille ben oui on la protège et moi
j'ai pas honte d'aller dans ce sens et
et je ne me considère pas comme
liberticide il faut arrêter de se
gargariser de mots
la liberté ça mérite autre chose que
cela
alors quand j'ai dit ça bah il ya deux
ou trois petites petites rectifications
je souhaite faire une précision
pardonnez moi le fait qu'on n'évoque pas
ici la radicalisation et la
déradicalisation dans les prisons ça ne
signifie pas qu'on ne s'y intéressent
pas et qu'on ne travaille pas je viens
de monter un groupe de travail notamment
avec eux le magistrat du pôle
antiterroriste à paris pour bien sûr
réfléchir et agir sur cette question qui
est une question très important ce n'est
pas parce que nous l'évoquons pas de la
même façon d'ailleurs ce qui se passe en
prison concerne notre loin gérald
darmanin l'a rappelé ce qui se passe
dans les hôpitaux concerne une autre et
ce qui se passe dans les écoles et
partout ailleurs
j'ai entendu également tout à l'heure
que madame la députée florennes je crois
vous souhaitez que l'administration
puisse déposer une plainte au lieu et
place de la victime qui a été ciblée et
vous avez raison parce que les victimes
qui sensibles et ont parfois
peur et à juste titre d'ailleurs et
quand nous connaissons malheureusement
l'actualité récente que nous avons eu à
connaître il ya parfois matière à avoir
peur donc que l'administration se
substitue oui naturellement j'y suis
tout à fait favorable
il ya un autre élément qu'on n'a pas
évoqué enfin que mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler bien sûr c'est
quand la haine vise les mineurs faut
absolument bien sûr les protéger d'où
l'idée d'aligner ses dispositions à
venir et de faire de cela une
circonstance aggravante bien sûr enfin
enfin le voile certains ont regretté que
qu'on n'évoque pas le voile moi je vais
vous en dire un seul mot rien seul ce
texte est un texte de principe le voile
peut signer l'asservissement
il peut aussi signé un choix est donc
rentré dans ces discussions là
maintenant c'est pour moi nous enliser
dans des débats qui ont déjà eu lieu
le président de la république dans le
discours des mureaux c'est pas si vous
en souvenez après le discours a répondu
à certaines questions qui lui étaient
posées par des journalistes notamment
sur le voir il a été très clair il était
déjà très clair à l'époque que le voile
ne viendrait pas dans ce texte c'est
vous qui le dites
mais je ne suis pas de votre avis et je
viens de vous expliquer pour quelle
raison parce qu'il est parfois un
asservissement
mais il est aussi parfois un choix et si
l'on se met à discuter de tout de tout
les vêtures et de tout ce qui peut
distinguer les uns et les autres dans la
pratique de leur foi
alors nous sortons de ce texte et nous
nous perdons ce texte il doit être me
semble-t-il consensuelle
c'est un beau texte il doit tous nous
réunir et moi je pense que sur un texte
comme celui là les clivages politiciens
peuvent être effacée au profit d'une
avancée commune pour les valeurs de
notre république
merci monsieur le ministre
madame la ministre chargé de la
citoyenneté vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés d'abord je tiens à
vous remercier pour la qualité de vos
interventions et pour le travail de fond
qui a été menée au cours de vos
auditions et au cours des échanges que
nous avons pu avoir et si vous en êtes
d'accord je voudrais assez brièvement
regrouper les réponses que je vais faire
à certaines des interpellations qui ont
été les vôtres
d'abord pour ce qui concerne la question
du contrat d'engagement je voudrais
rappeler comme je les dis qu'il est
vraiment construit avec les élus avec
les associations je sais que 700 à coeur
de monsieur le rapporteur est le député
pouya je sais vous êtes plusieurs à
l'avoir mentionné madame la députée
florennes je voudrais partager avec vous
le fait que le contenu de ce contrat il
est encore en cours d'élaboration et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas le texte
à l'heure actuelle parce que justement
nous voulons que cette construction
elles soient communes autour de grands
principes comme la liberté de conscience
la liberté d'association des membres
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la non discrimination la fraternité la
prévention de la haine et de la violence
le respect de la dignité humaine et le
respect de la légalité et de l'ordre
public et autour de ses grands objectifs
de ces grands principes
nous construisons le texte avec les
associations et avec les élus parce que
je rappelle que ce contrat d'engagement
il vient soutenir les élus locaux qui
courageusement ont été nombreux dans
tous les partis politiques de l ère des
élus du ps j'étais à montpellier
auprès du maire monsieur de la fosse qui
a souhaité mettre en place une telle
charte qui a été attaquée en justice par
un certain nombre d'organisations qui
nous semble important pour soutenir ces
maire et ses élus locaux qui travaillent
en première ligne de pouvoir faire
rentrer ce dispositif dans la loi et
comme nous sommes engagés avec le
ministre de l'intérieur nous
présenterons le texte dès lors qu'il
sera écrit aux parlementaires de la
commission spéciale et ce avant le
passage en séance afin que vous puissiez
et bien le le découvrir l'amendé le
débattre avant cela en ce qui concerne
peut-être un certain nombre de questions
qui ont été posées notamment sur le
député corbières sur la question de
pharos je partage complètement votre
objectif est d'ailleurs avec gérald
darmanin nous avons annoncé le
renforcement de pharos et son ouverture
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
les nouveaux policiers qui travaillent
chez pharos sont d'ores et déjà arrivés
ils sont d'ores et déjà en poste et il y
a d'ores et déjà une effectivité vingt
quatre heures sur vingt quatre et un
objectif de 7 jours sur 7 pour les
signalements de pharos nous avons
d'ailleurs réunis de nouveau le groupe
perde un contact qui n'avaient pas été
réunies depuis plusieurs années avec les
différents patrons des réseaux sociaux
pour que la communication avec pharos se
fasse mieux et se fassent surtout plus
rapidement
en ce qui concerne un certain nombre
d'amendements qui ont été évoqués je
voudrais dire aux rapporteurs que ils le
savent il ya une je considère avec mise
l'intérieur qui a une grande qualité de
leur travail à la fois juridiques mais
aussi sur le fond sur le sens et donc je
crois qu'il ya un certain nombre de
travaux qui ont été menés parlementaire
par les parlementaires pardon qui sont
de nature à améliorer ce texte est donc
bien évidemment nous le regardons avec
beaucoup de bienveillance je pense
notamment à la question de la fusion
entre agrément et contrat d'engagement
pour simplifier et rassurer le monde
associatif
à cet égard je voudrais dire à la
rapporteure madame la députée du bre
chirac nous entendons l' alerte sur la
situation des femmes qui sont victimes
de la situation de polygamie nous avons
travaillé nous avons commencé à lancer
un travail d'action publique pour
accompagner cette fois justement et je
voudrais dire que nous allons regarder
avec bienveillance l'ensemble des
amendements qui ont été proposées il
lorsqu'il s'agit de faire des
changements sémantique pour améliorer la
qualité juridique de ce texte
peut-être pour terminer rapidement un
mot sur la question de la laïcité
vous êtes nombreuses et nombreux à avoir
souhaité et avoue être manifestée pour
faire en sorte que la laïcité soit mieux
porter dans l'appareil d'état mieux
porter dans l'administration
et là aussi ce texte il n'a pas juste
une vocation immédiate il a une vocation
à transformer durablement et de façon
pérenne la manière dont la laïcité est
porté et défendu dans l'appareil d'état
et donc c'est pourquoi nous allons
déposer deux amendements du gouvernement
d'une part pour désigner des référents
laïcité dans tous les services publics
afin que le mariage soit réelle et que
la communication passe et d'autre part
pour mettre en place une formation
obligatoire de tous les agents publics
de tous les agents publics à la laïcité
comme plusieurs d'entre vous dans leurs
différents travaux l'ont sollicité ça
nous semble fondamental ce sera inscrit
dans la loi et donc ça pourra désormais
avoir valeur de loi si vous décidez de
voter ces deux amendements du
gouvernement et je crois que c'est là
aussi l'illustration à la fois du
travail commun du gouvernement avec les
parlementaires mais aussi l'illustration
de notre volonté collective de faire en
sorte de transformer les choses en
profondeur pas uniquement dans les
textes mais véritablement dans la
réalité et dans ce que doit être une
administration au service des valeurs de
la république française au premier rang
desquels la laïcité je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
petite précision parce que j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure le garde des sceaux dire
on ne parle pas du voile dans ce texte
c'est je tiens tout de même à préciser
d'abord qu' il n'y a jamais eu de loi en
france contre le voile à une loi en 2004
contre les signes ostentatoires à
l'école que par ailleurs il y à une
jurisprudence du conseil d'état sur la
neutralité des services publics que
l'article 1 du projet de loi inscrit
dans la loi
non seulement cela mais les temps
à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
exercent des missions de service public
même s'ils appartiennent les entreprises
privées à des associations etc et donc
les amendements qui porte sur sept
articles notamment et qui évoque les
signes religieux y compris le voile ces
amendements ont bien sûr été déclarée
recevable je tiens à le préciser parce
que j'ai lu dans les médias où j'ai lu
sur twitter que j'aurais censurer les
amendements sur le voile alors vous
pensez bien d'abord que ça n'aurait
aucun fondement juridique
c'est comme si on voulait écrire des
choses dans la loi sur les associations
cultuelles musulmanes non on fait une
loi de portée générale
donc il y a les associations cultuelles
par exemple il ya les signes
ostentatoires il ya neutralité du
service public
il y à un article sur le service public
qui porte à la fois sur les agents du
service public est étendu à ceux qui
exercent des missions de service public
qui mentionne les usagers du service
public et donc tous les amendements qui
porte sur ces sujets ont bien sûr été
jugée recevable et qu'ils intègrent la
préoccupation du voile car bien sûr on
peut parler comme tout un chacun on sait
bien que cette préoccupation existe dans
notre pays chez nos concitoyens et chez
un certain nombre de nos collègues
alors je vous propose puisqu'il nous
reste un peu plus de 20 minutes que nous
prenions quelques questions et donc
qu'ils sont je le rappel limité à une
minute et ensuite les ministres pourront
répondre je passe tout de suite la
parole à monsieur julien ravier du
groupe l'est républicain
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
monsieur le président chers collègues
après l'horreur de la décapitation de
samuel pâtit après le cruel assassinat
de croyants catholiques à nice il était
grand temps de prendre à bras le corps
la lutte contre l'islamisme et je
voudrais donc d'abord salué cet
indispensable texte je reviendrai pas
sur les éléments positifs qu'ils portent
il y en a et nous les soutiendrons pour
autant ce texte ne va pas assez loin
je l' ai déjà dit souvent en audition
d'abord il ne nomme pas l'ennemi
l'islamisme politique radicale et
séparatistes résultat il crée des
dommages collatéraux dommages
collatéraux sur la liberté d'exercice
des cultes d'associations
et également d'instruction finalement
vous voulez conforter les principes
républicains en restreignant nos
libertés et nos droits fondamentaux
c'est un véritable paradoxe pour un
texte de liberté avons nous entendu par
ailleurs vous abusez de l'interprétation
de l'article 45 ça a déjà été dit pour
museler un petit peu le débat sur le
respect des principes républicains pour
les partis politiques c'est tout à fait
étonnant sur le respect des symboles de
la république à l'école notamment les
dracs plausible alors ma question est
simple et j en janvier à ma question si
vous permettez monsieur le président
avez vous peur de fracturer la majorité
en abordant ces questions fondamentales
de lutte contre l'islamisme radical
pour premier et lutter enchères entre
l'agent question sur le fond du texte la
parole est maintenant à monsieur thomas
rudigoz aux du groupe la république en
marche toujours pour une minute et je
serais assez stricts sur le respect du
temps de parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre et ses ministres il ressort de
l'avis du conseil d'état comme des
auditions menées par notre commission
que le projet de loi comportant les
principes républicains
alourdis certaines contraintes
administratives auxquelles sont
assujettis les associations cultuelles
et mist je pense notamment à la
déclaration de qualité cultuelle en
préfecture tous les cinq ans je pense
aussi aux nouvelles règles relatives au
financement des cultes à savoir par
exemple la certification des comptes
annuels pour le par un commissaire aux
comptes en cas de financement étranger
je soutiens totalement cette mesure mais
estime avec d'autres que le seuil
financier envisagée n'est pas le bon et
va grandement compliqué la tâche de
petits lieux de culte aux faibles moyens
humains et matériels
certes les obligations créé par ce texte
sont en partie compensé par des
avantages nouveaux accordés aux
associations cultuelles tel le nombre
minimal de membres requis pour
constituer une association cultuelle
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
est il possible que vous preniez en
compte ces doléances portées par les
représentants de quasiment tous les
cultes jour merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le député la parole est
maintenant monsieur philippe vigier du
groupe modem
thomas en téléphone merci monsieur le
président madame monsieur le ministre
deux points rapides dans ce texte on
aurait aimé voir quelle place un peu
plus large qui soit donnée à la
formation à la laïcité la lutte contre
le séparatisme dans le monde associatif
mais également en direction des élus
locaux
quel est l'avis du gouvernement là
dessus puisque ces amendements étaient
jugées irrecevables
la seconde chose c'est concernant et en
particulier pour gérald darmanin sur
l'article 5 ap l'article à l'article 114
du code de sécurité intérieure on parle
du plan de sûreté et que vous savez
monsieur mise à l'heure actuelle et des
emplois des secteurs des transports des
personnes y compris leurs sous traitants
donc on font l'objet de criblage de
recrutement par le sne et à ce qu'est ce
qui n'aurait pas été judicieux que pour
d'autres secteurs notamment je pense au
domaine de l'éducation
je pense à celui de la santé on puisse
utiliser ces mêmes types de fichiers
enfin dernière question sur la
possibilité qu'ils auraient pu être
donné avec ce texte de rendre inéligible
plus quand il a inscrit sur le fichier
des signalements pour la prévention à la
radicalisation à caractère terroriste
dans la mesure où le préfet apporte la
preuve objective que le candidat
présente un risque avéré pour l'ordre
public
quel est l'avis du gouvernement sur ce
point merci monsieur le persil monsieur
le député la parole est maintenant
madame anne laure blain du groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président il y aurait
tant à dire après les réponses des
ministres et notamment du garde des
sceaux qui finalement évoque un certain
nombre de sujets mais je crois que c'est
qu'il doit tenir dans nos débats
c'est véritablement le souhait de fixer
un cadre républicain et nous mettre au
delà de l'organisation et de l'immixtion
dans l'organisation des cultes et
effectivement ça a été dit lors des
auditions un certain nombre de cultes
regrette que les changements qui sont
dans cette loi rentre bien trop dans
leur organisation vous parliez au site
où tous les ministres présents parlait
d'un texte de liberté je reviendrai sur
deux notions en ce qui concerne cette
liberté une liberté peut-être qui
existerait pour tout le monde sauf pour
le parlement en vertu de l'utilisation
de l'article
5 qui en a été faite par la majorité et
notamment par là la présidence de cette
commission et puis aussi un texte de
liberté mais qui sacrifierait une
liberté fondamentale qui est celle de
l'instruction et vous parlez de
l'intérieur l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant mais malheureusement en est en
ce qui concerne l'école publique
aucune disposition éducative n'a été
évoquée voilà donc je voulais proposer
la parole est à monsieur belkhir
belhaddad du groupe la république en
main merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres a le
discours de la président de la
république le 2 octobre aux mureaux
montré la voie et donner le cap à
parcourir pour réaffirmer faire vivre
nos principes républicains le
gouvernement a su transformer large
partie en actes qui sont remerciés
une autre partie méritera encore
notamment sous l'angle de l'égalité des
chances et de la lutte contre les
discriminations que nous y consacrions
encore du temps dans cette législature
pour moi ce texte met en oeuvre des
protections protection de notre
république certes mais protection
également dans l'exercice des cultes
dans l'association dans l'association
est dans la vie associative de la mise
en oeuvre des services publics
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
alors où nos oppositions et certains
médias ne voit qu'au des contraintes
quels sont pour vous les moyens qui
seront mises en oeuvre pour rendre
effectifs ces mesures protectrices
merci merci monsieur le député la parole
est un monsieur pierre yves bournazel du
groupe agir
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
madame et messieurs les ministres la
lutte contre les dangers du séparatisme
est un combat qui demande du courage
la responsabilité du discernement et un
esprit d'équilibré
je salue l'engagement du gouvernement
dans ce combat long et difficile contre
toute forme de radicalisation
il demande à s'inscrire dans une logique
opérationnelle de diffusion de nos
principes intangibles de laïcité de
liberté d'égalité et d'unité les
associations jouent un rôle majeur
d'éducation de solidarité d'inclusion et
d'animation auprès de la population à
travers leur mission elles assument une
responsabilité imminente dans la
transmission des principes de la
république
aussi notre groupe est attaché à ce que
le contrat d'engagement républicain soit
assorti
une mesure complémentaire rendant
obligatoire la formation des cadres
associatifs à la laïcité et à la lutte
contre les discriminations ce serait là
un levier décisif est positif de
transformation de notre société
pouvez-vous m'indiquer si le
gouvernement est favorable à cette
ambition je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député et la parole
est maintenant monsieur charles de
courson du groupe liberté territoire
madame la ministre dans votre réflexion
actuelle sur le fameux contrat
d'engagement républicain il y aurait-il
y aura-t-il un contrat unique pour
toutes les catégories d'associations ou
y aura-t-il un contrat type par
catégories d'associations sport culture
culturel social et est-ce que le
gouvernement va t-il dénoncé les
articles et des quatorze conventions
bilatérales de sigoyer social prévoyant
un partage des pensions de réversion des
étrangers ayant travaillé en france
merci beaucoup monsieur le député la
parole est à monsieur alexis corbière du
groupe la france insoumise toujours pour
une minute
merci merci président je voulais
interroger le ministre et l'éducation
nationale sur le fait que tout de même
eu un grand absent sur le renforcement
d'écoles publiques qu'ils creusent et du
respect de nos principes républicains
j'aurais pas l'idée d'une élégance de
faire monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur j'ai répété tout à l'heure
les propos de madame rolland responsable
du renseignement territoriales qui avait
dit à l'occasion d'une audition que sur
les 2400 2500 les deux pulls qui avait
moins d'une centaine qui posait problème
vous venez de dire que ce chiffre est
faux c'est une illustration me
semble-t-il qu'on a un problème de
constat de chiffres partagé car si même
au terme de nos auditions ont fait au
pas de charge les éléments qui nous sont
donnés sont contestés par le ministre ou
commanderait qu'à l'arrivée tout ça
devient un petit peu compliqué et enfin
monsieur dupont moretti j'ai souvenir de
votre parole extrêmement forte
lorsque vous étiez avocat pour dire que
si un homme même le pire des hommes dont
toulouse et défendit alors un homme qui
avait commis un attentat terroriste est
accusé sans preuves alors cédé
terroriste qui aurait gagné
moi c'est mon propos je suis pour être
efficace contre les terroristes
je suis pour que nous avancions avec des
constats et des éléments réels
et non pas toute une série d'impressions
qui nous amène au bout d'en avoir des
propos blessants je termine jaud est
clair président et que je dire monsieur
le garde des sceaux
lorsque précisément nous demandons à
l'ensemble des associations cultuelles
qui désigne le ministre du culte de
changer leur statut et notamment la
fédération protestante alors qu'ils
n'ont rien à voir avec ce texte
puis je considère que nous introduisons
dans ce débat des choses qui
restreignent les libertés
la parole est maintenant un madame
caroline abadie du groupe la république
en marche merci monsieur le président
nous l'avons compris ce combat contre le
séparatisme ne se mènera pas que dans
les lieux de culte à l'islam politique
s'est déployée sur internet depuis déjà
de nombreuses années
nous sommes très heureux de voir dans ce
texte arrive et la régulation des
réseaux sociaux
elle est bien sûr indispensable mais ne
sera pas à notre avis suffisante et nous
utilisons tous depuis 10 ans 20 ans les
réseaux sociaux mais savions nous tous à
notre première connexion ou avons nous
tous en tête à chaque connexion se
ferment ce phénomène d'enfermement
algorithmique ce phénomène de dépendance
au like aux écrans et tout ce
qu'implique l'économie de l'attention en
termes de haine en ligne la prévention
l'éducation seront donc bien sûr le
pandore nécessaires à cette régulation
dès le plus jeune âge avant l'entrée au
collège des enfants doit être
sensibilisé aux bons usages d'internet
au collège ensuite pour poursuivre cet
apprentissage
aujourd'hui des gendarmes et des
policiers arrivent à sensibiliser près
d'un quart des enfants d'une même classe
d'âge
mon groupe uni derrière ce texte
derrière le gouvernement portera un
amendement pour généraliser ce type de
formation à tous les enfants d'une même
classe d'âge merci beaucoup madame la
députée la parole est un monsieur
philippe benassaya du groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur président présent la
république avait dit aux mureaux on l'a
dit le 2 octobre dernier le problème
c'est le séparatisme islamistes alors
c'était un point de départ intéressant
et à l'arrivée point où peu de
séparatisme jusqu'au titre qui en a
gommé la référence alors exit le
séparatisme est aussi existe aussi tous
les ferments du séparatisme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure mais notamment le premier
foyer le premier producteur de
séparatisme en france à savoir le monde
carcéral j'avais déposé d'ailleurs
plusieurs amendements sur ce sujet sur
la lotte 2009 qui prévoyait
l'encellulement individuel destiné
vite et l'endoctrinement groupe
amendement jugé malheureusement il
recevable alors à quoi sert une loi qui
évite l'essentiel et qui nous a noyé
dans une avalanche d'audition pour se
donner l'apparence d'une ouverture pour
finir dans une sorte de débat limitatif
je pensais que ce texte le président
pouvait nous rassembler autour des
valeurs de la république
mais monsieur le garde des sceaux ce
rassemblement ça se construit ça ne se
décrète pas ce texte tiède et sacrifié
sur l'autel d'un juridisme strict mais
dévoyée de l'article 45
puisque nos amendements compte amiens
directs et indirects de la loi merci
merci monsieur benassaya on ne va pas
refaire ce débat indéfiniment je passe
tout de suite la parole à monsieur
ludovic mendes du groupe la république
en marche merci monsieur le président ce
texte de loi que nous étions nombreux à
attendre va nous permettre de garantir
le renforcement des principes
républicains
je tiens à saluer la volonté du
gouvernement de faire de la protection
de l'enfance un pilier de ce texte
législatif
il protège l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
sans jamais stigmatiser une partie de la
population
les seuls qui doivent se sentir
concernés ce sont les prêcheurs de haine
les militants pour la chute de la
république et celles et ceux qui
souhaitent imposer un mode de vie à une
population tous ceux qui souhaitent par
ce texte tenir des propos stigmatisants
ou amalgamant trouveront sur leur route
des défenseurs de la république qui
n'accepteront jamais la mise à l'index
d'une partie de nos concitoyens qui sont
d'ailleurs souvent les premières
victimes du séparatisme
notre seul et unique objectif par ce
projet de loi c'est de faire société
en recréant l'appartenance collective à
notre nation qui s'est effritée au fur
et à mesure de discours fracturant
prononcé aussi bien par les combattants
d'idéologie idéologie nauséabonde que
par une partie de la classe politique
mes chers collègues je nous souhaite de
débattre sereinement sur le projet de
loi pour nos concitoyens
pour la république pour l'histoire de
france soyons à la hauteur je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à monsieur
xavier breton du groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président madame et
messieurs les ministres
pour m'inscrire en faux contre ce que
vous avez à dire des gens qui auraient
eu une grande concertation très souvent
dans les auditions que ce soit les
milieux associatifs et éducatifs des
cultes etc
il ya eu un regret sur le manque de
concertation préalable au dépôt de ce
projet de loi c'est un projet de loi qui
souffre d'un double défaut tout d'abord
il ne va pas assez loin sur un point
c'est la lutte contre l'islamisme
radical
et on peut regretter à ce sujet que les
amendements qu'on avait déposé à ce
stade et bien été refusée au titre de
l'article 45 mais c'est aussi un texte
qui d'un autre côté va trop loin il va
trop loin avec des mesures de portée
générale qui vont s'appliquer à tout le
monde et qui vont avoir des des dommages
collatéraux en s'attaquant à des
libertés la liberté d'expression la
liberté d'association la liberté
d'enseignement la liberté de culte ou
effectivement il ya des citoyens les
associations qui ne manquent de rien qui
vont être concernés par ce texte qui va
compliquer
et leur vie et on peut le regretter
autant de raisons vous le comprenez
monsieur ministe d'intérieur vous
cherchez des d'éviter qu'ils allaient
s'opposer à ce texte
autant de raison de s'opposer à ce texte
merci monsieur le député dernière
orateurs monsieur françois cormier
bullygeois du groupe la république en
marche
merci monsieur le président cette loi
est une loi de liberté cela a été
beaucoup dit ce soir je crois que cette
loi importante et essentielle est aussi
une loi qui protège comme l'affirmé
lacordaire entre le fort et le faible
entre le riche et le pauvre entre le
maître et le serviteur c'est la liberté
qui opprime et la loi qui affranchit la
loi protège oui la loi de 1905 en
instaurant la liberté absolue de
conscience à apporter une protection à
touche aux athées aux agnostiques aux
chrétiens aux juifs aux musulmans
nous devons poursuivre cette oeuvre
législative protectrice en rendant juste
et parfaite l'obligation de neutralité
dans la sphère du service public
j'aurais des propositions à faire aux
socios d'ailleurs par voie d'amendement
mais auparavant
pour la clarté de le débat monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur j'aimerais
comprendre à qui fait référence
l'article 1 quand il évoque s'agissant
de ce qui doit être étendu la neutralité
je cite les personnes les personnes sur
lesquelles il
il est un organisme de droit public ou
de droit privé chargées des exécutions
d'une mission de service public
il exerce une autorité hiérarchique ou
un pouvoir de direction lorsqu'ils
participent à l'exécution de service
public je vous remercie merci monsieur
le député et je donne tout de suite la
parole à monsieur le ministre et à
madame la ministre si vous le souhaitez
sachant que nous avions dit que nous
arrêtions à 20 heures bon on peut
toujours aller un petit peu au-delà
détail pratique mais qui a son
importance la buvette de l'assemblée
nationale prendra les dernières
commandes à 20h50 à monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président je les permettre de me faire
une citation de la loi de 2004 celle qui
interdit le voile des signes ostensibles
pardon à l'école un seul exemple
demain le port du voile sera interdite
mais suit du caissier sera autorisé
pourtant le défi peut apparaître en
particulier pour les jeunes juifs comme
aussi une dégression je m'inquiète aussi
pour l'intégration
c'est la grande affaire est il
raisonnable de commencer par stigmatiser
exclure autant il faut combattre
fermement toutes les formes de
communautarisme autant ce serait une
erreur de voir dans toute expression
identité l'affirmation d'un quelconque
communautarisme il yad'ailleurs
communautarisme que lorsqu'une
communauté agressé autres notre pardon
excusez moi le grand défi républicain
réside seulement est désormais dans la
cyclo sécularisation l'islam de france
dans cet esprit je suis prêt à prendre
part ce qui peut parc est la mienne
on ne construit le plus de musulmans
comme un aimant président et passion
c'est de loi ne servira à rien
marc le fur 2004 parce que ce qui est
très intéressant pour répondre à
monsieur ravier c'est qu'il faut pas
chercher à avoir des divisions oyonnax
il y avait 29 députés du groupe ump qui
n'ont pas voté en 2004 pour des raisons
tout à fait compréhensible pour des
raisons qui fondent la liberté la
culture politique cohérent et je préside
et d'autres parlementaires qui font pas
d'heures partie de vos rangs aujourd'hui
et il ya et c'est bien normal dans les
discussions des groupes politiques des
discussions importantes et politique au
sein du groupe plr comme au sein du
groupe en marche comme au sein du groupe
modem comme dans d'autres j'imagine
expression politique il faut pas des
caricatures et commencé par dire vous
n'avez pas fait telle disposition parce
que des peurs de diviser la majorité
mais ce serait faire peu de cas du débat
politique est ce que vous êtes tous
d'accord messieurs du rhdp l'air sur
l'instruction à domicile entre monsieur
diar et madame thunder j'ai noté des
différences plus que notable entre
certains députés verts qui disent qui
vote quoi qu'il arrive le texte va
maintenant discuter un autre qu'ils on
verra bien j'ai des différences puisque
notables et c'est bien normal et jeudi
au groupe socialiste
monsieur glavany disait monsieur glavany
non mais on n'y était pas il y en aura
pour tout le monde
monsieur de la vanille disait monsieur
dernier disait qu' il était contre la
disposition présentée par le
gouvernement de 2004 du président chirac
parce que à l'époque les l'air avait la
laïcité honteuse il a émis ostensible
plutôt visible qu est l amendement
proposé par le groupe socialiste
parce qu'ils avaient une inspiration
religieuse qui était du côté du groupe
mais peut-être y la laïcité et à d'abord
d'où une loi de gauche à l'inspiration
de gauche donc je crois qu'il faut pas
se moquer en tout cas moi je
souhaiterais que cet argument de
tribunes facile parce qu'il ya d'autres
extraits évidemment très intéressant et
on peut citer chacune et chacun
pardon en 2004 j'étais en 2004 j'avais à
peine le bal que vous c'est que vous me
prêtez beaucoup de mai mais ne portait
pas ne portait pas trop de turpitudes
monsieur le député je voudrais dire que
il est normal d'avoir des politiques et
philosophiques sur les textes aussi
important et je crois que le garde des
sceaux a eu raison de rappeler que tout
n'est pas si évident a priori
voilà donc moi je crois que on peut
avoir un débat serein sur cette question
sans pour autant jeter des anathèmes de
lâcheté ou de trop grande autoritarisme
le deuxième s'il ya des des amendements
qui seront déposés dont cobras en
discute le deuxième sujet est évoqué est
celui de monsieur de monsieur breton qui
dit finalement ce texte il est trop beau
pour ce qu'il a dû être dur pour ce qu
il admis monsieur breton entrant dans le
vif du sujet d'autres évoquant
simplement la fin plutôt que le fond
mais monsieur breton vous auriez aimé
sans doute mais on aura le débat que
nous fassions à texte admin m pour le
culte musulman c'est ce que je comprends
de vos propos il aurait été absolument
contraire aux principes de l'art et plus
le texte il est trop beau pour ce qu'il
a dû introduire pour ce qu il admis
monsieur breton rentrons dans le vif du
sujet d'autres évoquant simplement la
forme plutôt que le fond mais monsieur
breton vous auriez aimé sans doute mais
on aura le débat que nous fassions à
texte admin m pour le culte musulman
c'est ce que je comprends vos propos il
aurait été absolument contraire aux
principes de l'art et plus